what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with Avengers versus X-Men
versus eternals the Judgment Day event
and this story here's the thing this
first issue pops off I mean it's just
like boom it just it hits hard what this
initially does here is it picks up with
a kind of discussion between Tony Stark
and Cersei of the eternals now one of
the things to know is that for a lot of
new comic book readers this is cool if
you are an older comic book reader this
is a throwback to like the 80s and 90s
right this is a throwback to the days
when like Cersei and the eternals were
far more involved with human Affairs
than we've seen recently specifically
Cersei she's been very very important
when it came to just the overall history
of the Avengers the X-Men all that kind
of stuff there's a lot of stuff there
and so it's kind of cool to see because
it takes me on a bit of a Nostalgia trip
from way back in the day but the thing
about this is that there's kind of a
conversation that's going on between the
two now one of the things to know is
that Cersei while her and Tony Stark
have of course been together physically
a variety of times and so on she never
really took them all that seriously and
that's because despite all of his wanted
intelligence and all that kind of stuff
Tony Stark never really took himself all
that seriously right he's a jokester
he's a Playboy right he's the guy he's
got it where it counts but he just kind
of passes himself off and puts himself
off as a guy that never takes anything
seriously so nobody ever really takes
him seriously that's one of the reasons
why the Civil War Story was so important
is because it was one of the very few
stories that used that you've seen over
the course of Marvel's publication
history that focus on Iron Man outside
of like demon in a bottle or armor Wars
or something like that that showed a
very serious side of Tony Stark which
was really really cool but the thing
about this is that as they're having
this conversation there is a bit of a
discussion about how effectively the
eternals are now aware of the fact that
the X-Men have the power of Resurrection
now this was actually brought to the
eternals by way of someone named the
Jack of knives Jack of knives is an
eternal basically Jack is one of the
Eternal crime Lords and that's one of
the things we'll talk about as we go
through this video is how the eternal's
roster and the overall system is kind of
expanded really under the writing of
Kieran Gillen of course largely being
done most likely as a result of the MCU
but that when that information was
brought to the eternals the question is
well what do we do with this now and
initially the eternals were like who
cares it doesn't really matter that was
until the concept of excess deviation
was brought in which is that mutants are
basically an offshoot of the deviants
that's somewhere along the line a
deviant Gene entered the human genome
likely through procreation and that all
major that exist now are basically a
result of humans possessing a deviant
Gene that's what the X Gene is now I
have ever since this was introduced we
did a video on geek culture explained
where it's like that's Marvel the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is in for mutants in
the Marvels in the MCU that's how
they're going to introduce they're going
to say the mutants are basically just an
offshoot of the deviants done right
that's why this is being done there's no
other reason to alter the entire history
and the origin of mutants outside of
that there's really no reason to do that
so the fact that they're doing it here
that's what really changes things that's
why it matters is because it's going to
become an MCU thing but in the midst of
this conversation suddenly you end up
having uh basically Cersei who's taken
by the uh taken by like Echo and Thor
and Captain Marvel basically like
attacked and whisked Away now the reason
why this is done why she's overpowered
is because Cersei if you're gonna take
her out you've got to be quick because
Cersei is a matter manipulator she's not
Universe wide she can't alter reality on
a universal scale but she can't alter
the structure of people she's facing off
against knock them unconscious any
number of things so if they attacked her
and the battle went on for more than
like a minute Cersei would basically get
the upper hand with a quickness that's
how powerful she is right somebody who's
able to overcome basically almost
anybody up to a particular limit most
Earthbound people and so that basically
allows the Avengers to take Cersei away
and so what this does is it switches
over to the X-Men at the tree house in
New York now remember for those guys who
are catching up with us the tree house
is basically the X-Men's field base in
the city of New York they do exist in
krakowa but the tree house is kind of
like a a field base right it's where
they can operate out of specifically the
main X-Men team Cyclops Jean Gray
different things like that now what's
kind of funny here and this is something
that has not been explicitly addressed
yet at the time that this comic was
launched is that Cyclops is basically in
his normal Garb he's not Captain krakowa
so we're still fleshing out exactly how
that works in relation to the greater
landscape because remember cyclops's
death was public people aren't supposed
to know he's still alive but one of the
things that gets talked about here is
the fact that the the story of Ben yurik
that we had covered previously which was
him basically revealing to the world
that the the mutant population has the
ability to resurrect themselves that
this has become known and not everybody
has reacted to it in a positive way some
people have reacted to this in a
predictable way which is that oh my God
the mutants had the ability to come back
to life well now they're more of a
threat than they ever were as other
people are reacting to it with anger
right like a woman's daughter is still
dead how come the X-Men get to come back
and her daughter doesn't the reality
here though is that Cyclops goes as far
as to say that the five can only really
bring back certain people specifically
those whose Minds have been backed up by
cerebra that's one of the caveats that
was established during Hickman's run
that if they brought back This Woman's
dead daughter she would just be a body
with no memory of who she was before
literally she'd be just kind of teaching
her everything new so it'd be her
daughter who had returned but her
daughter wouldn't know who she was again
it's one of those things where Cyclops
isn't saying that the five can't bring
them back literally it's the five can't
bring them back as they know them which
is what they want they want the you know
that woman wants her daughter to come
back as she knew her daughter that kind
of a thing and so what ends up going on
here is you basically have a kind of
meeting between Nightcrawler and Destiny
and Mystique now remember what's been
going on since the return of Destiny is
Marvel's largely been building on her
ability to see the future now the way
that Marvel plays this and it's one of
the coolest things about it Destiny has
a wide and varying way in which her
ability to predict the future works the
most popular version and the one that
there was an entire story arc based
around was called Destiny's Diaries
basically these instances where she had
written down how things could play out
in the future and it was people's desire
to find those Diaries so they could
basically they could ensure that things
unfolded in the way they wanted to or
stop particular things from happening
and so what this does is it kind of
segues into the modern era which is if
something's going to happen in 10
minutes Destiny knows right off the bat
if something's gonna happen in a day or
in a week or a month she can predict it
pretty accurately but if we're talking
about something in 50 years it may or
may not come to fruition because a lot
of things can happen in the span of 50
years that can prevent that from
happening specifically what Destiny does
here is she says the eternals are coming
right the eternals are going to try to
kill us all this war is right around the
corner it's like right there and I can
see it coming and so in response to that
Nightcrawler basically travels to arako
right travels to Mars and then
essentially tells storm and and Magneto
and all those guys we have to assemble
the quiet Council we've got to assemble
the great circle or great the great Ring
in Oracle basically their governing body
we have to make sure people know the
eternals are coming for us all the thing
about this is that Destiny does not
specifically know why the eternals are
going to do it she simply just knows
that they are right that she's predicted
that they are going to go to war with
the mutants and if the mutants are not
prepared they're all going to die now
the funny thing about this is that it's
kind of approached in different ways
storm herself is like okay we have to
approach this from more of a political
standpoint how do we deal with this on a
political perspective Magneto's host
stance is we will take like we'll
confront this Force when it comes head
on and he even goes so far as to say
that like the eternals are the old gods
right they were created by the
celestials these beings that were
supposed to keep the world safe and all
that kind of stuff we've moved Beyond
them we don't need the protection of the
eternals we have our own cure for for
death right we've solved the equation of
Resurrection we are more powerful than
they are and we're larger in numbers
than they are they're simply launching
this attack against us because much like
the humans they're afraid of their own
mortality we represent the next stage of
not really just Evolution but the next
stage of moving beyond them right if
they are our parents we are the children
ready to step out into the world and he
even goes as far as to say we are the
world's new Gods now and so that's kind
of the funny thing because at that point
you transition to Avengers Mountain
which is where at least is a place deep
inside the mountain where essentially no
telepathic abilities will work so no one
can read the mind of Iron Man and Cersei
I mean she can read his mind I guess but
she can't telepathically call for help
literally it's one of those things where
it's like no one can hear you scream
there's no one you can call for so you
better start answering my questions and
again she just doesn't really take him
seriously you know she's she's literally
mocking him you know he's like if you
were in my shoes what would you do and
that kind of a thing and she's like I
would never be any shoes because you
know you're you're they don't they don't
look good right they wouldn't look good
on me that's when the conversation gets
serious where he's like I'm not joking
here I'm not [ __ ] around I'm not
goofing off right like I am serious here
I am 100 serious right like I totally
get that you were doing your thing that
like you as eternals you have your own
Society you're not really a family you
have your own campaigns and what have
you and you do your stuff and that's
fine right it's always been that way you
do your thing we do our thing you don't
show up for every Avengers crisis event
and we don't show up for every eternals
event but it becomes an Avengers problem
when we find out that Thanos exists on
Earth that he's here and he's running
the eternals right now at the moment
Thanos has been defeated but that entire
story arc right where Thanos was on
Earth and running the eternals the
eternals Never Told The Avengers and the
response of Iron Man is this is a
problem not only that Earth was minutes
away from destruction and at no point
did you tell us what was going on that's
when it becomes a problem right so these
are kind of two different events
happening at the same time and so
ultimately the response of Cersei is I
regret that and Iron Man's like that's
the problem Cersei you regret it but
you're not sorry about it there's no
apology here right you don't even say it
was a mistake your regret was not the
fact that you didn't tell us your regret
was that we found out that's the issue
that you have and that's why this is a
problem and so ultimately because of how
this interrogation is going in the end
Captain America shows up here now this
is a great moment because what it does
is it highlights how Captain America is
viewed by everybody right he literally
shows up and he's just like this method
of interrogation isn't working Tony
Stark and here's the thing Cersei was an
Avenger at one point we have to show her
some level of trust and he tells her the
eternals are going to war with the X-Men
tell us what you know and Cersei again
plays the same card she did with Iron
Man where she's like well I mean I know
that war is significantly more likely
now that you've strapped me to this
uncomfortable and unfashionable chair
and Captain America just looks at her
and that's when she realizes okay this
is serious that's the nature of Steve
Rogers and it's a very easy thing to
overlook it's one of those things you
look at Captain America and it's like I
mean he's cool he can run fast and punch
hard rahu right he'd make a great
Olympian yeah you know the USA champion
in whatever competition he happens to be
in but the truth about this is because
of the things that Captain America's
done over his time as a superhero and
because of his standing among just
anybody on Earth human mutant Eternal
otherwise everybody respects him and
they know that when Captain America gets
serious when he stops joking that's when
things are a problem and that's why
Cersei stops she drops the act and she's
like you're serious a war an actual War
like like and so she's like what do you
know right like you have to know
something you wouldn't just kidnap me
bring me here and then tell me a war is
coming without having something to
verify that's the case and that's when
Iron Man's like okay so since everything
popped off with Thanos so we learned
about all that stuff we've basically
been monitoring all Eternal activity and
what we found is that there was
basically Celestial energy that spiked
and then ended like almost immediately
and there's response Associates but
that's not that's not weird like cosmic
energy like literally your Fantastic
Four have cosmic energy that's not
uncommon and his response is these are
like a series of low-level Rumblings
that are happening around the world
something's warming up something in the
earth is coming and because of the fact
that you as eternals have Celestial
energy right you're powered by cosmic
energy and you've been here for like a
million years who else is it gonna be
right and so it's like what are you
doing what do you have going on and the
response of Cersei is here's the thing
you need to understand we as eternals
we're a society we're not a family right
we don't owe anything to each other we
use the terms of familiar relations
mother father brother sister but we use
that as a stand-in for teammate right we
we use it in that capacity we consider
ourselves I guess a family to a degree
because there is a finite number of us
there will never be any more eternals
they're not being created anymore we
cannot die we'll always come back but we
can leave at any point in time and some
of us have some of us have abandoned the
eternals and we've taken up residents
with the deviants so here's is the thing
you need to understand I'm not the
Eternal that you have to worry about
here and so what you do is you switch
over to Olympia the capital of the
Eternal City and you have druick who is
the Prime Eternal he's the one running
the show addressing basically what will
become the unimod and essentially saying
here's the problem we as eternals were
created for the purpose of one keeping
deviant the Deviant population in check
and two correcting excess deviation
which is a time where the Deviant Gene
becomes corrupted right like when
deviants experience a mutation of their
own essentially but unlike the human
population that experiences a mutation
and they develop a healing factor or
they become Charles Xavier who can read
minds when a traditional deviant
undergoes excess deviation they turn
into some grotesque monster and actually
start killing other deviants we
eliminate them and he's like but here's
the problem somewhere along the line the
Deviant Gene entered the human gene pool
and now mutants are excess deviation our
job to follow our Charter the task
assigned to us by the celestials if we
we are going to correct I.E eliminate
excess deviation we have to kill the
mutants so I am asking the unimind to
vote on this I'm asking the unified to
support this and the unimind agrees and
so what this does is it leads to to
druick visiting Uranus in the exclusion
now arenos is one of the original
eternals when the eternals were
initially created right which is to say
like they were initially formed by the
celestials Uranus was one of the first
and he is one of the most powerful of
the eternals now initially it was
believed that he was dead and in fact he
was kind of killed to a degree instead
of him being resurrected he was kind of
sort of a patchwork clone but the
reality is again using the kind of
familiar relations he is by all
standards the measurement the
grandfather of Thanos right like
literally that's who he is he's that
powerful he's on that level of scale and
it's one of these cool things where
drewig says okay if we are going to
launch an attack against the mutant
population you're you are arguably the
most powerful of us so we are going to
give you a task he says you have an hour
one hour the machine has coded you to
return here instantly right because
remember the whole idea behind erinos is
the and the reason why he's locked up is
that during the early days when the
eternals were initially created Uranus
thought that the best way for the
eternals to maintain their role was to
literally eliminate all humans and all
all deviants and then just conquer the
world and then spread out from there
that led to a civil war among the
eternals and he was effectively killed
for lack of a better word but then
cloned and brought back so he's not a
truly resurrected Eternal and so that's
why he's a prisoner here because the
ongoing fear among the eternals is that
if he is released he would incite
another civil war among the eternals or
perhaps just simply try to kill them all
and then refuse to resurrect them
because he who is the Prime Eternal is
the one that controls the machine and he
who controls the machine decides who
gets resurrected and so what what Uranus
says in one of the most amazing
statements ever he says my own people
have forgotten me these mutants made
Mars habitable in a day but to destroy
is always easier a human takes nine
months to make another breathe a human
can crush a windpipe in seconds you will
see what your reynos the undying can do
with an hour and so he basically goes
forward on his mission and will find out
what that is what this does is it
switches over to druig as part of the
Damocles Foundation now the Damocles
Foundation was founded way back in the
day its Mission has basically changed
now the Druid is the head he's like the
prime Eternal but initially the basis
behind the Damocles Foundation is that
it was a coming together of humans and
deviants and eternals who believed that
this kind of constant war that was going
on between humans or between the
eternals of the deviants and whatnot
would lead to the ruin of all and so
their goal was to actually find some
kind of a peaceful resolution to this
sort of Warring nature of their
differing societies and then try to see
that come to fruition sometimes this
work sometimes it hasn't they've usually
operated behind the scenes but they've
never really seen their goal come to
fruition but what ends up happening here
is you actually have druick who's
meeting with Maura McTaggart and really
she's allying with him with the idea of
finding a way to eliminate the entirety
of the mutant population because
remember more McTaggart was the one who
started krakowa in the first place and
unbeknownst to Xavier and Magneto when
they allied with her to create kruhoa to
create this mutant Utopia that what more
McTaggart actually wanted to do was
slowly eliminate the mutant Gene so
there would be no mutants because in
every life that she lived right her
power was to basically die and then to
come back to life in essentially a new
reality right kind of a restarting of
the universe so to speak that in every
single future that she saw mutants were
always killed mutants were always
destroyed by the forces that they were
going against right humans post-humans
you know whatever the case happened to
be so her idea was to essentially slowly
phase out the X Gene remove it entirely
and save the lives of mutants by getting
rid of mutants completely and so when
that was brought to fruition she was
stripped of her powers using the gun of
Forge right which basically nullifies
abilities and she was kicked out of
krakowa and so as a result of this she
kind of Harbors this Vendetta where one
she has a kind of personal Grudge to
want a secret KOA fail but two she's
steadfast in her Mission and so as a
result of this what ends up happening is
there a kind of agreement that's struck
where it's like I will do what I can to
work with you because right now uh more
McTaggart is allied with orcas right for
those of you guys who aren't following
the X-Men comic orcas is just this
organization that exists out there that
is a combination of of like Hydra and
advanced idea mechanics and like former
Shield agents and things like that who
are all working to bring down the X-Men
and so her outline with the eternals
basically provides the eternals with the
resources of orcas because for the
moment their goals are aligned and so
where you what you end up having is
Druid revealing that what the eternals
are doing is launching a three-pronged
attack which is genius in terms of how
this unfolds and that's what happens
when you face off against the eternals
they've been around for a million years
they've watched Wars they've fought Wars
they've observed them they've seen how
things go on right they see how how to
win in a conflict the military strategy
of Captain America is nothing in
comparison to the strategy of the
eternals because they've just been
around for so long and so what ends up
happening is the the first prong of this
attack is the unit mind of the eternals
at least those who are still under the
controller at least under the leadership
of uh of Druid the prime Eternal that
unimind launches a telepathic attack
against the against the quiet Council
and those telepaths who exist on krakowa
right Charles Xavier Jean Gray those
guys right that kind of unified front
with that telepathic attack happening
right Exodus and all those guys with
that telepathic attack happening what it
does is it keeps them distracted it
keeps them focused on that attack on
that conflict while that conflict is
happening basically foot soldiers are
sent in right and these foot soldiers
offer another distraction for The Other
Guys Wolverine and Laura Kinney and
cyclops and magic and all those guys
right and because of the power of these
forces everybody literally runs to
krakowa right like all the X-Men and
everybody they bail out on a Rocco they
run to krakowa and they fight the battle
there now while that's going on two
other things go on so I guess it's more
of a four-pronged attack two other
things happen the next phase of the
attack is for Druid to actually send in
Jack of knives when Drew extends Jack of
knives in because Jacob knives is an
eternal that can render themselves
invisible that what it does is it allows
Jack to get in there and start killing
the five right remember the five are the
ones who resurrect mutants and so this
is this is just ridiculously awesome by
targeting the five it destroys the
ability for mutants to be resurrected or
at least that seems to be the case now
in order for that to happen in order for
Resurrection to be in it entirely all of
the mutants have to like all members of
the five have to be killed the problem
is that Wolverine catches up to Jack of
knives now under normal circumstances
Jack of knives would be undetectable to
Wolverine Jacob knives can Mash their
scent to the point that Wolverine can't
pick it up but what wolverine does pick
up is the blood on the dagger that Jack
of knives was using which is a genius
Strat it's just a genius piece of
writing here and so basically it allows
Wolverine to essentially stop Jack of
knives from killing all the members of
the five and so this is when you get to
the final phase of the attack as is
outlined by Druid right the Jack of
knives did technically fail and were
more mctaggard is like you had your one
chance to destroy the ability for
mutants to resurrect themselves the
response of Druid is patience right you
are looking at things in the short term
because you haven't lived as long as I
have it's all about patience right at
the very least we will have eroded their
numbers and when the questions asked by
more mctagirl what about all the mutants
the the one million mutants that exist
on a Rocco right what about all of them
the response of Jewish is they're not
our concern because what you end up
finding out is that the task of Uranus
was to go to Morocco to go to Mars and
kill every single mutant there and he's
seemingly done exactly that cable
Magneto all those guys storm he
eradicated them all that's the power of
Uranus that's how powerful that guy is
he killed them all seemingly on his own
and so he's immediately teleported back
as soon as that hour is over druig
teleports back to uh to the capital city
right the exclusion Zone on the in the
capital city of the eternals and that's
when he's told by Uranus you're gonna
need me again right you have to let me
out you're going to need me and the
response to Druid is if that time comes
then we will let you out but until then
that's not going to happen and so in the
face of all of this right with this
attack launched on the X-Men the
entirety of the mutant population Uncle
KOA just in disorganized disarray right
the mutants on a Rocco those individuals
who can be resurrected have been
resurrected right basically the mutants
just kind of left in a state of panic
and Chaos having no real idea on what's
going on the response of druig is to
actually tap into the the world's
electronic systems and broadcast live
simultaneously to every human around the
world and what he says is this he says
people of Earth I am Druid of the
eternals I am speaking to you via your
extremely impressive high-tech devices
and that's when like Captain America
realizes everybody's getting this
message even the Avengers are watching
this message Andrew says I could use
telepathy but we consider that intrusive
and cross it's a Nouveau immortal move
and yes I'm talking about these mutants
they're a threat to you all they have
overstepped their natural bounds and
clearly aim for a Dominion that
stretches across worlds and Eternity we
apologize that we've let them go so far
but rest assured we serve you as we have
for a million years and humanity is
championing this humanity is celebrating
this right the basically the Eternal
stepping up and saying we will eliminate
the mutant threat for you but Druid says
however we must ask you to not be afraid
of the Towering death machines that have
emerged off the Western Seaboard of the
United States they are not towering
death machines they are the hex and they
are eternals yes we're not all
human-sized but rest assured whether
large or small we are your protectors
that said we would advise anyone in any
coastal regions to head Inland as
swiftly as they can it's possible this
may get messy now this is one of the
things that's been going on with the
eternals comics those guys who haven't
really been watching our videos on it
the entire basis behind Kieran gillen's
realm with the eternals is to expand
them drastically it's an entire society
and it's way more than the eternals that
we were initially introduced to in
Marvel Comics there's so much more to
them than that they come in all shapes
and sizes all forms it's wild how this
is going down it's really really cool
and so in response to all of this
Captain America assembles The Avengers
and so what happens is that while the
Avengers are being assembled and trying
to find some way to respond to what the
eternals are doing Iron Man picks up on
on basically an intrusion alarm and when
he gets there he basically finds ajak
and he finds Makari now the funny thing
about this is that they're basically
getting in the same way that like they
had gotten in before which Iron Man kind
of takes is a little bit of an insult
but they've also got Sinister in tow
which explains why Sinister had
basically vanished from the X-Men's
quiet Council where it is that he's been
all this time he's being held captive by
the eternals and the idea here the goal
of the eternals at least those who have
broken away from Druid who don't really
operate under the Eternal main society
right so think of them as like the uh
like the American separatists that broke
away from England and like founded what
became the United States that's kind of
what the eternals are to a degree but
the thing about this is their job is to
say okay look this is a holy war right
like what what drewig is doing is He is
building what he's building his actions
based on the the you know Godly decree
right the holy decree of the celestials
which is we as eternals correct excess
deviation he's using that as a reason to
wipe out the X-Men so if it is Gods who
established this then it is God who can
correct this we need the celestials to
make this happen and we need a God as a
Celestial that can do this for us right
that can establish a new law and when
the questions asked by Iron Man okay I
mean this is interesting but where the
hell are you going to make a God in a
few hours the response of macarian ajac
is look around you man we're literally
inside of a dead Celestial it can't be
that that impossible to resurrect him
and the reality is that it's not
remember back in back in 2008 during
Charles noff's run which is the the at
least one of the eternals runs that we
have so we'll create a playlist for
Judgment Day so it all kind of comes
together and makes sense that the
eternals do have an afterlife they visit
the fulcrum once they basically quote
unquote die right the fulcrum being an
aspect of the one above all uh they do
have like a kind of afterlife you can
recall a dead Celestial you can bring
them back now whether or not that
happens is something that we'll see over
the course of this story but I gotta say
man Judgment Day hits with a bang I'm
trying to figure out if we should do
this like just over the course of the
week and then like every other day just
do like a second video
um or if we do this as like a weekly
thing right because the weekly thing
just it makes it so exciting just kind
of anticipate it but I had to cover this
story right so here's the thing this
story focuses on Exodus and those are
the guys who have been following the
X-Men Mythos as we've done it so far
right Jonathan Hickman's run going into
Jerry Dugan's run and all that kind of
stuff you've seen Exodus just kind of
lingering around but you've never really
seen him fight and in fact you never
really got a whole lot of insight in the
mind of Exodus which kind of sucks
because actually this has been around
for a long long time right so Exodus he
originally appeared way back in 1993
with X Factor issue number 92 and in
fact he became a part of Magneto's
acolytes when he was quote unquote woken
up by Magneto in X-Force issue number 25
which I'm pretty sure was released that
same year but what's really funny about
his character though is that despite
being introduced in the early 90s we
didn't get an origin for him until Black
Knight the One-Shot story that was told
in 1996 that it picked up off of a
defender's story which basically saw
that Dane Whitman the Black Knight and
Cersei of the eternals were basically
time displaced and they ended up in the
12th century and we'll talk about that
here in a little bit but what this
initially does is it basically picks up
on kind of the origin of of Exodus of
Ben and do Perry now this is a smart
decision to make by Kieran Gillen it's a
genius decision because Exodus is a
character people are now aware of but
only because of his time on the Kawaii
Council and everything going on with
Jonathan run up until now
um but he's a character people don't
know the story of and a lot of people
don't know just how ridiculously
overpowered this guy is it's it's crazy
how powerful he is so the thing about
this is that video Perry initially Rose
to prominence during the Crusade this
initially opens up when he's actually
out in the desert and he encounters the
Phoenix Force now it doesn't possess him
but he simply just meets him and it's
one of those things where it was the
first time that he actually encountered
anything that could really be referred
to as a god despite the fact that he was
fighting in the Crusades up until that
point it was just some disembodied being
that exists out there in The Ether right
whose word he follows and like that was
it that was really all there was but
seeing the Phoenix Force physically
manifest actually instilled in him of
Faith but it was actually a faith
predicated on mutants now the thing
about this is he didn't know he was a
mutant at the time we'll talk about how
he reconciled that here in a second but
what it does here is it jumps back to
krakowa and it basically picks up with
everything that he's talking about it
really just like why AI Council
themselves who were talking about how a
war with the eternals are coming right
so this takes place slightly before the
events of Judgment Day number one proper
but it's one of those things where
they're kind of like you know how do we
come to terms with this right one uh
Nathaniel Essex right like Mr Sinister
he's been kidnapped and we don't know
exactly how to cope with this like if
he's been taken by the eternals they've
literally started a conflict by
basically kidnapping one of our own how
do we respond in kind without
instigating a full-scale war now on one
side you have what are basically the
more level-headed people right so Emma
Frost to a degree Charles Xavier so on
and so forth on the other side you have
the warhawks like Sebastian Shaw who
were like no we can't operate on the
defense it's offense we have to go and
get him and then if a war starts
whatever let the chips fall where they
may right we are the mutant population
there are more of us than there are
those eternals we can take them on but
the reality here is a Sebastian Shaw
painfully misunderstands just how many
eternals there are and what form those
eternals take and that's one of the
things that's really being hit on here
during the judgment day story is that
the eternals are not simply just the
people that we've seen Marvel published
stories about over the course of the
last however many decades and like
that's it that the eternals are huge in
number and there's a variety of them all
over the world that we simply just
didn't know about which is kind of
interesting because in a lot of ways the
Judgment Day event and the the whole
revelation of the eternals of Marvel
Comics is very much following the
inhumanity storyline and I'm sure a lot
of you guys who are aware of inhumanity
coming out of the storyline that came
out of like Infinity right that story
itself which basically dealt with uh
Black Bolt detonating the terrorism bomb
spreading the terrigen myths across the
world and then all these people who were
in humans and didn't know it suddenly
just waking up to become Inhumans right
just going through Terror Genesis like
you know Kamala Khan and like all those
different characters it very much feels
that way to a degree except it's really
more that we're discovering the fact
that they've always been here as opposed
to the fact that like they're just now
coming into existence but one of the
things that happens here in Xavier is
really kind of the top guy in the quiet
Council albeit unofficially they are all
technically equal in power but because
of Xavier's history with the X-Men he's
kind of like the number one guy sort of
everybody just kind of suddenly agrees
on that that he really looks at it from
the perspective of saying okay like the
reality here is that the eternals they
hold no grudge that we know of we
expected orcas we are not prepared for
war against them but from exodus's
perspective he's just kind of hitting on
this and he's like sinister's gone this
is suspicious for dozens of reasons we
should Purge him from the quiet Council
and it's one of those things where as he
thinks and as he analyzes he looks over
at Destiny and he sees that Destiny has
a kind of small Twitch in her chair
which is enough for him to realize him
just having these thoughts could
potentially have a massive impact on the
future now remember it's very difficult
for Destiny to predict what's going to
happen based on what somebody's thinking
or things that are supposed to happen in
the far-flung future she's very very
good at predicting on the battlefield
it's one of the reasons why when she was
part of mystique's Brotherhood she was
instrumental in their ability to defeat
the X-Men because literally they would
be in the heat of combat and she would
be like Gambit's coming from that
direction and like they would be able to
overpower Gambit before he even got
there it was just one of those things
right I might go back and cover those
older X-Men stories because there's just
so many callbacks in this run and it
makes me really nostalgic for it but
what he ends up doing is actually
talking about how Destiny currently sits
in the chair of apocalypse and
apocalypse is gone and then he has a
flashback to his own history and says
apocalypse is here but here is not now
and it's one of those things where he's
literally jumping to his own origin
story now this is one of the things to
to explain here right because what you
end up having is this situation where
you basically end up having Cersei and
Ian garrington who essentially meet with
Exodus after he becomes Exodus so to
fill in these gaps here which are not
readily explained by Kieran Gillen and
to actually give you the origin of
Exodus the way this played out is that
as part of the Crusades that Exodus and
I guess Bennett do Perry which is what
he's initially known as an iobar
garrington are basically trying to find
What's called the Tower of Power now the
Tower of Power itself at least as it was
a explained in the old black knight
Exodus story it's not really a tower of
power in a literal sense it's the home
of the Eternal Pharaoh now what they
don't know is that it's actually the
home of Apocalypse they really don't
know what they're getting into here but
the way this story played out is that it
was actually picking up off the heels of
an existing Defender story where the
Black Knight dained Whitman and Cersei
were effectively time displaced and so
what it did is it led to them arriving
in the 12th century when that happened
the mind or Spirit or whatever you want
to call it of Dane Whitman entered the
body of iobar garrington who is
basically his ancestor right he's one of
the the older black knights that existed
in Marvel Comics before Dane Whitman
became the Black Knight and so what that
did is it led to Dame just kind of
occupying the body but not actually
having control that iobar himself had
control and so that's why if you go back
and you read that story that something
seems a little off about eobar
garrington when things first pick up and
he talks about how like he had seen a
woman and like the whole thing feels
like a dream to him but he eventually
encounters and when that happens he
abandons the quest with Bennett duperry
who continues on his own and so
ultimately he ends up coming across
apocalypse and apocalypse puts him
through these kind of Trials which even
now are not readily explained in this
particular comic at least even in just
this one the immortal X-Men tie-in for
Judgment day but the important thing
here is the trials were done in the
manner by which apocalypse normally
conducts trials which is to say it was
testing the mind body and spirit of
Exodus to determine whether or not he
was even worthy of any enhancements
apocalypse could give him ultimately
Bennett was proved worthy and in doing
so apocalypse realized that benedu Perry
was a mutant he activated his x-gene and
then Amplified his powers and what it
did is it pushed Exodus to becoming an
Omega Level telepath and telekinetic the
guy's wildly powerful I mean this guy
has an advanced like an accelerated
healing factor it's not really on the
same level as Wolverine but it's a
really it's an exceedingly capable
healing Factor the guys got enhanced
longevity his telekinesis is so
fine-tuned that he can actually alter
the molecular structure of matter now
Marvel's never moved that past just
surface use right they've never moved it
into the realm of him being able to like
alter matter on a universal scale
arguably he could Marvel just doesn't
really do it so think of it more of like
a soft cap on his powers they just
haven't really explored that part of his
character yet but even beyond that the
guys telepathy is on the on the same
level as Jean Gray Professor Xavier
those guys he can teleport to virtually
any distance anywhere it doesn't really
matter where it is the guy's
ridiculously capable but having those
Powers augmented and having his
abilities Amplified also added a caveat
and the reason why is because in this
story and this this one that we're
covering here as well as in the old uh
Black Knight Exodus stories that what
happened is that as a testing initially
apocalypse instructed Cersei and uh and
iobar to kill Exodus which they refused
to do he then instructed Exodus to kill
them which he refused to do and in fact
he turned on apocalypse and actually
ended up fighting apocalypse and trying
to overpower him right because again and
exodus being a guy who's very much you
very much follows religious convictions
comes to the realization that apocalypse
is by all standards of measurement a
false god and in fact he declares him
that that apocalypse is not the God that
he purports himself to be he's just a
really powerful guy and so when Exodus
turns on apocalypse apocalypse
overpowers him and then locks him away
now the biggest issue that you had to
contend with when it came to that is in
later stories Exodus just demonstrated
levels of power that were so high that
it left people asking how in the hell
could apocalypse beat this guy and so
what Marvel did is they added in the
caveat that his powers are tied to his
confidence if he's surrounded by the
right kind of people or if he is if he
has full confidence in himself that
Exodus Powers reach their total Peak and
this guy is an absolute monster when
he's operating at his Peak but even when
he just believes in himself his power is
more than enough to rival apocalypse and
and really even overcome apocalypse and
that's how Marvel fixed that is by
saying that at the time when he
initially fought apocalypse he wasn't
entirely certain of what he was capable
of there was a little fear when it came
to apocalypse and he didn't have the
highest amount of confidence in himself
and that's how in Saban newer was able
to defeat him and so following that he
was effectively locked away now one of
the things that this does is it jumps
back to the modern era right following
this kind of flashback it jumps back to
the modern events when the eternals
launch the attack of the unamine right
like literally uniting their minds
together and launching a telepathic
attack against the against krakowa and
the quiet Council and so as that happens
of course the telepaths themselves are
able to fend off the attack but the
funny thing here is that we're Xavier
and everybody else is basically
struggling to hold their own then it's
doing it with the greatest of ease he's
he's able to hold he's able to just hold
it off right and it's just kind of like
yep I mean it's it's a thing that I'm
dealing with because while he's dealing
with the unimind he's flashing back on
his own memories which if anything this
is a testament to how powerful he is but
then following that he kind of touches
back in his own history and talks about
how he had slept for hundreds of years
and then was ultimately woken up by what
he thought was a another not really a
mutant God but a kind of Messiah he was
woken up by Magneto now again this is in
the old X-Force Comics X-Force number 25
and this is when Magneto arrives and
purports himself as a messiah because
this was old school Magneto or really
kind of new old-school Magnum this is
during the X-Men Vol 2 era and that in
effect what had happened is that when
when Magneto woke up Exodus that Exodus
ended up joining his acolytes now the
acolytes of Magneto were amazing back in
the day Fabian Cortez and all those guys
but basically they were like people who
were just religiously devoted to Magneto
they saw him as a God in a lot of ways
right the Messiah who was going to bring
about the positive change that they had
been looking for which was to basically
eliminate this the you know Humanity in
terms of its hatred of mutants and to
either lead mutants into a better place
which in this instance was basically
Avalon or it was to eradicate the mutant
population in its entirety so the
mutants could live on earth without fear
of of humans hunting them but the thing
about this is that beneducari came to
the realization quite quickly that that
basically Magneto was no really not
really a messiah or anything like that
if anything he was kind of a prophet but
much like apocalypse he was just a
mutant who was out there who was
purporting this idea that he could lead
people into a better future and so
ultimately Exodus became disillusioned
and ended up walking away now of course
jumping back to the to the current
events again this leads to uh to
Wolverine showing up and saying like
there's some kind of Silent Eternal
running around here and is killing off
the various members of the five now we
saw that during the Judgment Day story
if you guys recall that you literally
had that Eternal uh who was killing the
members of the five and that Magneto was
able to stop her before they could go on
like eradicating everybody because once
the five are gone there's no way to
resurrect anybody anymore right because
the five are the means by which people
are resurrected so there's no way to
resurrect them so that's why they're
they're really kept in the Hatchery
they're kept exceedingly well protected
by the mutants in fact they're protected
more than Xavier and Magneto art right
it's it's they're like the entirety of
krakowa lives and dies by the members of
the five they almost Hope Summers and so
on and so forth and so it's a really
really cool thing because what what
Exodus does is in listening to all of
this you know like Emma Emma Frost
talking and all these guys he's like I
need to interpret this situation in a
way that I understand and so he's like I
am a knight right and I am in the desert
and this force is not the eternals that
I'm facing off against it's just a
dragon right I'm interpreting it in a
way that just makes the most sense to me
and so literally it's one of those
things where he kind of mulls over this
whole situation and then he starts
thinking about Hope Summers and that's
when he comes to this realization or
really just kind of gives us this
realization that he had that for the
very first time in the history of his
life he encountered what he actually
thought was a true Messiah and the
person he views as an actual Messiah and
it's the reason why Exodus has such a
reverence towards Hope Summers on the
island of kakawa you've probably noticed
it as you've been reading the different
X-Men Comics we haven't heavily focused
on it because in all honesty I didn't
know if they were ever gonna really
explore it at all but they are here like
Karen Gillen is focusing on it here and
the reason reason for this an exodus
even says that is he says when the
Scarlet Witch he refers to her as the
Red Witch but he says when the Scarlet
Witch altered reality during House of M
and then set everything back and in
doing so took away 98 of the mutant
population's Powers reduced the
population down to about 198 mutants
then he was one of the only mutants that
retained his abilities now different fan
bases have argued different things based
on the power of Exodus that Exodus was
so incredibly powerful that he
subconsciously used his own powers to
actually override the influence of the
Scarlet Witch so he could maintain his
own abilities again that's just total
fan speculation there's never been
anything in the comics to indicate that
was the case although it'd be amazing if
it were true but regardless he looks at
this whole thing and says like for a
time there were so few of us left I
thought we were on the brink of
Destruction I thought our Extinction was
imminent but the truth is that in the
main Marvel Universe following the
events of House of M decimation and all
that kind of stuff that's when you
basically started coming into Hope
Summers When Hope Summers popped up on
the scene you eventually got the 12
light storyline and the 12 light
storyline was basically Hope Summers
becoming the Messiah and the fact that
her birth solidified the return of the
mutant population to the main Marvel
Universe mutants started being born at a
higher rate right they were literally
coming back and so that's why Exodus
sees Hope Summers as a true mutant
Messiah and he takes it as a personal
mission in saying because the eternals
had launched an attack against hope and
because they almost killed hope that now
they have basically attacked what he
views as being his God right his Messiah
the Messiah of the mutant population and
so in response it's one of those just
it's one of these amazing things because
while they are able to overcome the
unimind this leads to the secondary
attack of the eternals which we talked
about at the end of Judgment Day when
you basically have these just enormous
eternals who aren't really machines they
are actually
Eternal beings that basically start
attacking krakowa and these things are
massive and Powerful we don't know
exactly how powerful but we know they're
exceedingly powerful and it's one of
these amazing moments where like Exodus
just had has this insane monologue he
tells Hope Summers right when home
summer says we're not ready for this
right we're not ready for those guys
that's the level of power that we as
mutants are not ready for the response
of Exodus is we are and I am right he
says return to safety and return the
Fallen Warriors to the field be an
inspiration guard the flame of mutant
life be yourself it is more than
sufficient and when she says what are
you going to do his response is their
dragon's hope what do you think I'm
going to do and he says I am the pope of
a new church like Peter was long ago he
says Peter was the rock upon which the
Nazarene mutant built his church and he
says yes I am that rock but I am also
The Rock in the hand of Cain I can build
or I can destroy and no one out there
can do it on the level that I can so we
actually get a countdown here now one
thing to know everything that you're
gonna see in this comic takes place over
the span of one hour so what this does
is this initially picks up on the planet
of Morocco write the great Ring now one
thing to remember the great Ring is a
Rocco's version of The Quiet Council
from krakowa for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with that the quiet
Council on gracoa is basically the
governing body of pretty much all the
Earthbound mutants that we're aware of
when you had like the whole ten of
Swords of van and Jonathan Hickman's uh
X-Men run and you ended up learning that
there was like a whole other dimension
that had all these mutants that were in
it instead of them residing on Earth
with the regular X-Men and gracoa they
basically took off to Mars that arako
the the great Ring is their governing
body that one of the things to know is
that the great Ring is composed
exclusively of Omega Level mutants there
are no mutants on here that are not
omega level in power that's why you have
iska the unbeaten is why you have cable
Magneto different people like that and
then you actually have mutants that are
from oracot so Aura sarata uh ludos
logos people like that who's actually
going to be really important as we get
further into the story but one of the
things that happens here is Abigail
brand shows up literally with one minute
left and basically tells them like okay
there's a war breaking out between
eternals the Avengers and the X-Men just
so you guys know we need to have some
kind of involvement in this right we
need to send our forces to Earth in
order to Ally with the krakowan mutants
to basically defeat the eternals because
the eternals are so astronomically
powerful and then defend off against the
X-Men now one of the things to know is
that Abigail Brand's presence here is
not really welcome technically speaking
she is the director of Sword the
sentient World observation and response
department but much like Nick Fury when
it comes to Shield she's kinda shady and
the thing about this is that she
actually wanted to install spies in a
Rocco that would basically feed her
information which basically became
public knowledge but the thing about
this is that as she's basically
communicating this message and as she's
saying that one of the things that
happens is you basically get this
prophecy right now what had happened
here somewhere along the line is you had
what was called it'll The Seer right
she's basically a Rocco's version of
Destiny from the X-Men comics on quirkoa
she can see the future and she's an
Omega Level mutant the difference here
is that she at some point lost her
tongue and so she can't actually speak
what it is that she sees they kind of
rely on her silence right her the kind
of Silent messages she conveys in order
to interpret things and So what had
happened is she had basically revealed a
prophecy right she says an empty heart
beats hardest an empty hand deals The
Impossible blow and the stalemate ends
with victory's loss that prophecy is
probably going to become incredibly
important later on down the line it will
become important for this segment here
but that may end up playing like a major
role over the course of the story but
again these guys don't know that they're
on a timetable right one minute 49
seconds 48 seconds 30 seconds right the
clock is counting down and it's one of
those things where they're just kind of
having this conversation like okay well
I mean who in the world are we gonna
send you know it's just for them it's
just kind of General business for the
great circle but then suddenly a blue
light emanates out of nowhere and
they're like what in the hell is that
and that's when you get the arrival of
Uranus now one of the things that
happens here is they say okay the war
has restarted doorsteps what is what's
the chance that we have of winning and
iska turns on them and then kills one of
the members of the of the great circle
now one of the things to remember iska
the unbeaten can never lose her mutant
power is that whatever she does will
basically guarantee her Victory or
guarantee the victory of the side she's
on now it can be manipulated that's what
we saw when we had that tournament that
was going on before when you had that
fight taking place between Scar and you
had uh Magneto so like it can be
manipulated it can be tricked in this
instance though what she's doing is
designed to illustrate that they're all
gonna die right they're all basically
going to fall now the only person who
really looks at the situation and comes
to the realization that the only way to
truly win is to defeat iska right to
basically kill iska the Nightcrawler
teleports over and then takes her off
the board with the intention of
basically taking her out but when that
happens once he teleports away with iska
then you got the arrival of Uranus right
the grandfather of Thanos now here's the
thing that I want I want to make this
perfectly clear when it comes to uranos
he's one of the OG eternals the original
eternals old school right depending on
how Marvel does this it could very well
be that Uranus is more powerful than
Thanos but he literally says like like
mutants you have excess like you are
excessively deviating and I have one
hour to correct you because remember
mutants are basically the result of the
Deviant Gene entering the human
bloodstream it's one of the great big
huge changes that Marvel's making which
I absolutely love I think it's one of
the coolest things but it's kind of nuts
because within the span of 30 seconds
Uranus kills 11 000 mutants like that
right in the span of 30 seconds and the
way in which he does this is that it's
not simply just an attack on Oracle one
of the things that had happened here is
that Druid who's currently the prime
Eternal when he released Uranus he also
released his weapons cash and so what's
happening here is that Earth and Mars
are not the only places Across the
Universe where mutants reside that some
of those mutants from Morocco actually
left Mars and took off into the universe
they created settlements on other
planets different things like that and
so what you have is the forces of Uranus
albeit you know autonomous drones or
what have you who are showing up at
these different locations and
eradicating all these mutants in all
these places for example in the skies
above Port Prometheus that's where these
things show up right in these locations
all these different spots right the
Valley of the fallen and so on and so
forth different places Across the
Universe so in a lot of ways it is quite
literally a universe-wide conflict now
one of the crazy things that goes on is
that six minutes into this right this is
six minutes in that what you have here
is Aura Serrata that uses her eye on
Uranus now one of the things to remember
is that or Serrata is an Omega Level
mutant that when she looks at something
they basically cease to exist she's
essentially an ultimate nullifier right
literally it's as if they never existed
in the first place it doesn't work on
Uranus it has no effect on him
whatsoever and so for whatever reason
that's not explained here this guy
survives the entire experience and then
takes Aura out following that one of the
things that happens and this is a crazy
moment which I hope we actually get to
see later on down the line Legion shows
up now Legion showing up here here's the
thing to remember when you're facing off
against Legion you're not just fighting
one Omega Level mutant you're fighting a
legion of Omega Level mutants right
you're just fighting as many Powers as
he has because remember Legion has all
kinds of personalities there's Susan and
sunshine there's the origamis there's
all kinds of people there right there's
all kinds of abilities that can
manipulate people in differing ways when
these different personalities take over
Legion himself just David holler on his
own is an Omega Level telepath and
telekinetic he's wildly powerful the
downside to this is that we basically
end up seeing Uranus kick off with
Legion the two of them fight and then
Uranus comes back literally the next
page we don't actually see what happens
between the two of them in this conflict
but nonetheless this is when you get to
see like the full on power of Magneto
and like one of the one of the greatest
moments in the history of Magneto so one
of the things that goes on here right
God is ridiculously amazing one of the
things that happens here right while you
have literally these forces that are
going through right these forces of
Arenas that are attacking in all these
different locations you have the forces
of Oracle that are thinning off as best
they can and then you actually have
Richard Ryder Nova who's actually
helping to defend the iroquo mutants to
the best of his ability but ultimately
he just can't seem to pull it off right
he just doesn't have the power to do it
on his own I mean he can hold off but in
the end like ultimately these mutants
are going to fall but one of the things
that happens is that Magneto enlists
Lotus logos now this guy is ridiculously
cool this guy can manipulate any form of
metal in existence and in fact he can
actually produce metal from his own
physical body which in doing so Magneto
just enlists that ability from him right
like this guy's feeding Magneto metal
and Magneto is using it on Uranus and
literally just like puncturing this guy
trying to encase this guy the whole nine
yards literally wraps him in metal
shards keeping this guy held in place
and iranos breaks out of it anyway right
like this is 13 minutes in these guys
are falling like flies and in fact
Uranus walks up on Magneto and just
punches a hole in his chest and kills
Magneto on the spot and so one of the
things that happens is that cable tells
his computer right he says bodies Slide
by zero weapon cash Omega one it's this
weapon that he has this giant gun right
the Omega one pulse rifle that is the
most powerful gun in Cable's Arsenal now
one of the things to remember is this
has to be provided in context because on
its own it's just a giant gun the cable
has rahu why is that special because one
of the things to remember is that cable
comes from a time when apocalypse rules
the world so this weapon was designed
for the purpose and could have
completely eradicated apocalypse cable
uses this and he fires it on orenos and
nothing happens right he keeps firing it
to the point that it overheats and it
doesn't affect Uranus at all that's the
power of Uranus right the fact that this
weapon which could just annihilate
someone like apocalypse who uses
Celestial technology that it has no
effect on this guy whatsoever and the
Falls keep coming right like the deaths
just keep happening that Uranus just
keeps killing every single mutant he
comes across annihilates all them he
takes out Abigail brand now here's the
crazy thing while all of this is
happening Fisher King is just observing
right he's literally just in his home
and he's aware of it taking place I
remember he's a baseline human but the
big on running Theory here is that
fisher king was not introduced for no
reason he was not introduced for no
purpose at all then in fact in the face
of all of this right the eradication of
all these mutants that are dying across
the entirety of Morocco that fisher king
is going to basically activate a subset
kind of like a Fail-Safe protocol for a
handful of mutants that we simply just
didn't know about it's one of the things
that people are speculating of is going
to be a kind of like super secret Inner
Circle so kind of like a Black Ops Team
which I'm excited to see if that's going
to be the case but one thing that I want
to hit at here Uranus had one hour to
eradicate as many mutants as he possibly
could on a Rocco to eradicate all of
them which includes a council full of
Omega Level mutants he did it in 20
minutes 20 minutes he killed them all
every single one of them now here's the
crazy thing we get this like amazing
monologue right we we're basically told
Daddy Uranus uses the remaining time
well right T-minus 60 minutes right the
hour is over and it says so is 98 of all
life in a 50 mile radius all these guys
are basically dead right Uranus leaves
satisfied he is supremely confident in
his ability to bring death in all the
ages he has never felt the need to check
his work in this he is foolish he has
spent the last hour on the planet or
Rocco and on a Rocco you always make
sure and so one of the things that
happens is we actually end up finding
out that Lotus logos had basically
survived now it wasn't just him and in
fact he's told by some disembodied voice
forgive me right like I had to hide you
I had to hide you and keep you protected
because you're the person that I have to
keep alive in order to help me and so in
response to this Lotus says he
challenged all of us we cannot yield nor
die too quickly this way I fight again
and take revenge for the bones that are
all laid here for all the people that
Uranus killed I'm going to get revenge
and the response here is no right do not
do that at the moment we have to be
alive we have to Marshal our forces we
have to find a way to strike back if we
do that now we will all perish we have
to unify and we have to bring an end to
all of this because literally logos is
just like okay so Aura sarata is named
only right her eye is injured in times
she can be healed and her power can be
restored and he says she has survived
much worse but her weapon will require
healing and Uranus's weapons will roam
unchecked we must strategize and the
response here is no right such
strategies are not the place for you
right you are not the one running the
show here anymore in the end I am the
one who sits at the seat of loss and the
seat of loss now seizes control because
this is a war and it's a war that we are
losing so if we are going to win we have
to follow a strategy that I have devised
literally Magneto survived having his
heart ripped out now this is the power
of Magneto as an Omega Level mutant this
guy what it looks like he's doing here
because we're not given a definitive
explanation this guy literally looks
like he's controlling the iron in his
blood to keep his blood flowing to keep
his blood pumping so his body can
function because remember once the
heart's gone there's nothing to pump
blood throughout the body and so
literally your organs your brain they
don't get the blood you need and then
you ultimately die but by Magneto
manipulating the iron in his blood and
keeping his blood flowing he keeps
himself alive that's the power of this
guy this dude has no heart in his chest
it's been ripped out of his body and
he's keeping himself going not only that
there's two things to take away from
this the first is that Magneto is a
master strategist I mean you're talking
about a guy who has at different points
in time over the course of his
publication history taken on any
combination of the Inhumans which don't
really matter because he and humans suck
the Avengers the other X-Men and even
eternals and has won he's done it
several times over this guy is a monster
not only that he controls the entirety
of the electromagnetic spectrum what we
saw here is a taste of the full power
Magneto has and the reason for that is
the second thing Magneto is pissed and
you talk to anybody out there who knows
anything about Magneto and they will
tell you man they will turn the sun when
Magneto gets pissed oh dude when Magneto
gets angry that's when the war just
begins but what this does here is this
picks up with the eternals who have
launched their attack against the X-Men
now we covered that in the last video
right we covered the eternals making
their attack against the mutant nation
of krakowa what the eternals did not
account for was the fact that krakowa
has some ridiculously powerful mutants
here some of the most powerful beings
that exist in the universe exist on this
island and one of them is Exodus which
of course we covered in Exodus quite
literally takes on one of these eternals
by himself and it's kind of a crazy
thing because when that happens he takes
this guy out with a quickness I mean it
happened so fast Exodus just destroys
these guys and that's to be expected
because remember Exodus is one of the
most powerful beings to ever exist in
the history of Marvel Comics the guy's
ridiculously op but the other part of
this is that you do have eternals all of
whom have varying Powers we don't really
get the specifics of this eternal's
power the one that Exodus destroys but
there is one that's attacking the other
part of the island that in fact Cyclops
and those guys are dealing with and that
one has the ability to manipulate the
fauna manipulate basically the plant
life and plant matter around the island
so much so that it actually starts using
the island itself against the X-Men now
they are able to hold their own to a
degree but in the midst of all this the
X-Men are met by the arrival of the
Avengers now I know you guys are
probably asking yourself but if this is
Avengers versus X-Men versus eternals
shouldn't The Avengers be fighting the
X-Men we'll talk about that here in a
minute but when the Avengers arrive on
the scene one of the things to know is
that their arrival here is one part due
to the fact that there's a massive
Calamity taking place but the other part
of this is because of the history
between the Avengers and the X-Men so
mostly guys who are familiar with this
bear with me here for a second for those
of you guys who don't know what this
means in Marvel Comics there was a story
that was called Avengers vs X-Men and it
was amazing because not only did you get
to see the teams fight each other Marvel
actually released a series of one shots
that focused on The Avengers facing off
against different members of the X-Men
so Captain America versus Gambit
different things like that it was a
really really cool series we might go
back and remaster when they announced
the X-Men and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the thing about this is
that the Avengers being here is because
of the fact that they didn't initially
want to fight the X-Men in The Avengers
vs X-Men story things just transpired
that way and so because of that there's
a kind of a mixed reaction here Exodus
does not want them here and exodus is a
member of the governing body of the
X-Men so his word goes a pretty long way
but in the end wahi is a member of the
governing body of protecting gracoa it's
not really left to Exodus in the cry
Council to decide it's left to the
WarChiefs and at the end of the day
they're just like the Avengers can join
now one of the things to keep in mind
here is that while this battle is going
on on krakowa that you do have a subsect
of the eternals that it actually
abandoned druick who's currently leading
the eternals themselves and he's the one
that's Waging War against the X-Men and
presumably The Avengers or at least
we'll see in the future of this story
and so because of that you do have some
of these eternals who are actually
working with Iron Man they're working
with Riri Williams also known as
ironheart they're working with them to
actually Revitalize Avengers mountain
now here's one of the things to
understand Avengers mountain is actually
a giant Celestial and it has been since
that story was introduced since it was
launched by Jason Aaron it's known as
the progenitor Celestial this is
arguably the most powerful of all the
celestials but the significance of the
progenitor is that it was here or at
least arrived on Earth due to an attack
it was already sustaining and because it
was basically dying from the inside out
when it was being killed by The Horde
who were basically kind of like the arch
nemesis of the celestials but what ended
up happening is that when it arrived on
on Earth quite literally its blood
seated life on the world and that's how
Marvel offers a modern day explanation
of where life came from on earth that is
a result of the progenitor's celestial
but the goal here of the eternals and
Iron Man and Ruby Williams is to
basically Resurrect The progenitor now
the thing about this and what's really
really kind of a funny kicker here is
that you basically switch back to the
Avengers and the X-Men facing off
against each other and one of the things
to know is that the the X-Men ever since
the launch of krakowa have had the
ability to resurrect themselves it's why
it doesn't matter whenever an X-Man dies
depending on the situation because the
Clyde council could decide not to bring
them back and there's no way for that
X-Man or that mutant to return but by
and large most all of them do so even
when you had the it was actually the
great uncle of Thanos but even when you
have the great uncle of Thanos who
showed up on on Mars where you have
basically another subsect of mutants
residing and killed 15 million of them
at the end of the day they can just
resurrect them all it's gonna take a
while because there's 50 18 million of
them but they can still resurrect them
at that point it just comes down to
whether or not the mutants on gracoa
want to but the thing behind this is
that uh Captain America literally tells
Cyclops hey we're definitely here to
help man but I wish you told us before
with everything that we've gone through
I wish you told us before that you had
the ability to basically resurrect
yourself and that's when Cyclops like
think about what you just said man after
everything we've been through you guys
waged war on us why would we tell you
that we have the ability to resurrect
ourselves and that's one of those
instances when Captain America is kind
of like okay yeah you kind of have a
point but basically the X-Men and the
Avengers team up to face off against the
eternals now the cool thing about this
is that again the eternals launching
their attack is happening in multiple
stages they're attacking the mutant
nation of krakowa that's where these
gigantic eternals called the hex that's
where they're focusing most of their
attack but one of the things to remember
is that Neymar the Submariner is a
mutant and as a result of that one of
the eternals one of the members of the
hex has gone to Atlantis now that member
of the hack has basically been dealt
with by a combination of the X-Men and
name of the Submariner who are basically
able to destroy it the problem with this
is that with this destruction basically
comes essentially an explosion
underwater and as you can imagine is
something that massive right is
basically as big as Galactus or a
Celestial if it were to just explode in
the ocean it's gonna create tidal waves
it's gonna create tsunamis earthquakes
all different kinds of things and what
this does is it leads to what's
literally a worldwide Calamity of
essentially these just coastal cities
being overrun and so what ends up going
on is the X-Men tell the Avengers get
out of here go deal with that threat
we'll continue dealing with this here so
where the Avengers leave the initial
kind of offering by Exodus is I told you
guys The Avengers were going to abandon
us and where night crawler chimes in and
says no no no the Avengers are on our
side that's not a fair assessment
Destiny chimes in now remember Destiny
is a mutant that can see the future the
further she looks into the future the
less clear her predictions come and and
so because of that because everything
going on here is such a huge event and
because Destiny is able to see pretty
accurately into the near future she
corrects Nightcrawler and says no that
is the case The Avengers really are
abandoning us here this is going to turn
into a war where we are going to be
fighting both the Avengers and the
eternals we're going to be waging a war
on two fronts so it's one of those
things to kind of correct that concern
that you guys had of okay is this really
gonna work no no this is exactly how the
event's going to play out it is really
going to be the Avengers versus the
X-Men versus the eternals now again
while that huge fight's taking place at
krakowa we basically jump back to Iron
Man to Mr Sinister to the eternals
themselves at least the ones who are not
Waging War against the X-Men and you
basically have them traveling around the
world to different locations and
basically grabbing little pieces of what
are celestials that have existed on
Earth at some previous point in time or
visited in some capacity there was a
point in the past where the thumb of
erisham the judge had basically been
left on Earth I know it seems kind of
weird but that's effectively take again
there was a point where a piece of the
dreaming Celestial who you guys probably
recognized as tiamu from the eternals
film that dreaming Celestial had been
buried on Earth at one point in time but
there is a kind of Life essence of the
dreaming Celestial that still resides
here on Earth at the same time you also
have the Destroyer armor of Asgard which
was created by Odin when they were
initially dealing with the third host
the Potential Threat of the celestials
and Odin and the asgardians and even
Zeus and the Olympians were all going to
go to war with the celestials they
ultimately never did the Destroyer armor
was annihilated and that's when the the
sky followers realize okay we're kind of
out of our league here
we're just gonna leave these guys alone
and let them do their thing but one of
the other big moments to know is that
when it comes to the history of the
celestials on Earth that they had not
just been involved with the creation of
the eternals and the X-Men or at least
mutants as they would come to exist in
uh in Marvel Comics but they also
created the deviance but the deviants
were the ones who initially waged war on
the celestials and so the celestials had
essentially annihilated most all of the
deviants and push them to the brink of
Extinction the reason why this matters
is because ever since that point in time
the deviants view the celestials with
reverence they view them as absolute
gods and so the significance of that is
there is no group on Earth that knows
more about the celestials than the
deviants themselves even though the
eternals were created by the celestials
even their knowledge is not that intense
their knowledge is not as in-depth as
the as the deviants are and so the more
significant part of this is actually
Tony Stark himself and this is genius
because in the Christopher Cantwell Iron
Man comics and partially even in the
comics of uh of the Incredible Hulk by
Donnie case there came a point where
Tony Stark had actually piloted a dead
Celestial now Tony Stark's done that
several times in fact there was one
point where he piloted the god killer
armor which was amazing and if you're
curious about that we do have a video on
that you'll see that card pop up here in
a second you're welcome to check that
out when this video is finished but it
was just a ridiculously amazing story
but because Tony Stark has experience
with basically using the bodies of
celestials and because his body
remembers what it means to be a part of
a Celestial his nervous system is
basically being copied and is going to
be the blueprint and so what this
basically means is that by them going
around and collecting all these
different parts and you've probably
figured this out they're going to use
this to rebuild the progenitor Celestial
they're remaking a Celestial now the
thing that happens here is we switch
back over to the X-Men themselves right
we switch back over to the mutant nation
of cocoa and again you have this massive
fight that takes place now where Exodus
had already destroyed one of the hex
eternals what this does is it leads him
to facing off against another Eternal
known as sign now one of the things to
remember is that Exodus isn't a telepath
and telekinetic of the highest order
this guy's power is rivaled by a very
precious few people and depending on
what era we're talking about in Marvel
Comics not even Jean Gray who was at one
point a host for the Phoenix force not
even Jean Gray's power is on par with
this guy but the full brunt of Exodus
power comes to bear earth when he faces
off against sun and in doing so sign
actually sends out this kind of
telepathic message to Exodus which he
ignores or potentially doesn't even
notice because of the moment where sign
simply says please don't but Exodus
basically detonates himself and in doing
so unleashes all of his telekinetic
energy at one time and Destroy sign the
Eternal now the thing about this and
this is what's so funny here is
initially the X-Men celebrate this as a
moment of reprieve they celebrate it as
okay we destroyed that that Eternal
basically everything is okay uh let's
just kind of keep on keeping on which by
the way I may have referred to some of
the eternals of celestials my bad the
giant robot things you see those are
basically eternals here the only
Celestial that's part of this is the
celestialis being recreated or being
rebuilt by Tony Stark and all those guys
but the thing behind this is and one of
the things to remember and this was
established during Kieran gillen's run
the dark reality of the eternals which
they didn't know about is that every
single time one of them dies they're
resurrected which they didn't know about
what they didn't know is a random human
life is taken to basically resurrect
that Eternal there's no Rhyme or Reason
behind why it happens so while the X-Men
do have the ability to resurrect their
own and they prioritize those who were
either the most powerful or those who
are basically fighting on the front at
the moment the eternals resurrect
themselves as well the difference here
is that when Exodus is resurrected there
is a kind of limit when the X-Men
resurrect themselves their minds are
basically backed up and so when Exodus
was resurrected it's the most recent
backup for his character essentially
meaning it was before this war broke out
so while he is telepathically reminded
of everything that went on for him it's
information when signed the the
Eternal is resurrected she remembers not
only the events and everything that
transpired but how she felt and when she
had begged for her life for Exodus not
to kill her and he did it anyway now it
involves hate and the the war is right
back on again that literally sign
immediately goes back on the attack like
shows right back up again goes right
back on the attack and when that happens
sign had remembered everything and
learned and that's the difference that
the X-Men are able to learn to a degree
but they're they're you know when
they're resurrected their memories have
to basically been be provided to them by
way of secondhand information and that's
what's going on here with the eternals
that the eternals being resurrected
they're resurrected exactly as they were
before like the moment they died they
remember everything including their
emotional state and they remembered
everything they saw all the weaknesses
and all the strengths of the conflict
and that's why sign looks at everything
going on and says okay the only way to
really basically stop these X-Men is to
destroy the island on which they live
and so sine immediately starts attacking
the island now it's one of these moments
where literally they're just like we
can't stop like we can't stop her like
Signs resurrected here like we just have
people coming back we're still in the
process of resurrecting like Exodus
could potentially destroy sign again but
the reality here is if he tried that
sign would actually stop him because
sign would know that's exactly what he
was going to do sign learn from the past
experiences and so literally all hope is
lost here the mutant nation of krakowa
is about to be obliterated even
Nightcrawler right a man of God is just
like please like please Deliver Us from
this and that right then is when the
celestial comes online and the celestial
immediately sticks his hand out and says
cease and like everybody stops the war
just stops just like that like the the
eternals back off everything just ends
and it's one of those crazy moments
because it's just kind of like okay you
know like you literally have Iron Man
and you've got Ruby Williams and you've
got the eternals who have sided with the
X-Men and the Avengers and who are like
okay cool everything's copacetic we
brought back this Celestial is under our
control nope wrong this is the most
powerful Celestial ever because it's an
amalgamation of all the other celestials
merged into one and using the bits and
pieces of technology that can be found
it's Frankenstein it's a Frankenstein
Celestial but it's still the most
powerful Celestial and unlike what they
had previously believed to have been the
case which was they could control it the
reality is they can't because it exists
therefore it judges and it literally
says people of Earth listen you are
bickering children the planet is ruined
you have acted with unrelenting
unkindness to one another you leave me
no option this is your judgment day you
have 24 hours to Justify Your Existence
you will be judged individually you will
be judged as the collective if there's
more good than evil among you you will
live but if you are found lacking there
will be no tomorrow I will annihilate
every single one of you what happens
here and this is one of the coolest
things right what happens here is you
basically have the frigiditor celestial
analyzing everybody here right looking
over every single person and the first
person he hones in on is Captain America
right he literally says once more
Captain America seeks to inspire he
thinks himself a leader one who sets the
drum beat for the world I will judge him
first and so he basically appears or at
least kind of manifests this sort of
perfect looking Captain America type
thing and says you are a dream of a
better country right that's literally
what you represent a better America you
have tried to inspire it for a century
this country is the world leader and the
world is what it is it is worse every
single day you Captain America have
failed Captain America initially rejects
this and is like we're not playing this
game right we're not doing the game with
this stupid thing we're basically
blowing off all of this and so in the
end he's like we need to figure out how
it is that we're basically going to
satisfy the Judgment of this Celestial
on a broader scale now that's one of the
cool elements of Captain America very
rarely does Steve Rogers ever succumb to
like mind games and Shadow tricks right
that almost never works on Steve Rogers
not because he's immune to it right like
a telepath could screw up the mind of
Steve Rogers with relative ease right
what makes Steve Rogers so cool is that
he has this level of fortitude and this
level of leadership that is respected by
everybody in pretty much the entirety of
the Marvel Universe but the thing about
this is we basically transition over to
the exclusion zone now remember the
exclusion zone is basically where
eternals are resurrected when they die
or it's where they're held prisoner
specifically we have Druid who again is
the leader of the eternals which is
basically fractured so you've got Druid
who's leading a group of eternals and
pretty much most of the Eternal Empire
that wants to destroy the mutant
population because they're quote unquote
excess deviation remember that's one of
the big things the story is doing is
it's establishing that mutants didn't
just arbitrarily come into existence
they're basically humans that have a
deviant Gene and have just developed
Powers as a result of that but Druid is
literally talking here to Uranus and
Uranus wants to be set free now remember
in the last few videos that we did we
saw how powerful Uranus was he showed up
to Mars which is a settlement that has
mutants on it but not just any mutants
they're all Omega Level mutants right
the most powerful of the mutant race and
he killed like 98 of them in one hour
that's how powerful that guy is right
he's just on a whole new level of
strength it's kind of crazy what we end
up having in this conversation is of
course Uranus who says okay the
celestials already judged Captain
America and found him to be a failure so
now the question is how long before it
judges everybody else and in reality
it's kind of a Race Against Time here
because the perception of Druid and
those eternals who were on his side is
that our mission as eternals is to
correct quote unquote excess deviation
which only ever comes in two forms
either it's deviants who have like
basically mutated further and they have
to be destroyed they become deviants
that basically kill other deviants and
even eternals or it's humans with a
deviant Gene that have develop Powers
I.E mutants and the fact that he's like
we haven't killed basically every mutant
on Earth that's the failure of our
Charter that's why it will judge against
us and so his stance is we have to
eradicate them as fast as possible now
where you do have the druid-led eternals
which are like we have to kill basically
all the mutants on Earth if we possibly
can and then you've got those eternals
that are working against him Tony Stark
basically working alongside the eternals
that stand on the side of the X-Men
along with basically Mr Sinister who's a
mutant that they kidnapped ultimately
Tony Stark's approaching this from the
perspective of like how do we shut down
that Celestial now one of the things to
remember here is Tony Stark has
experience with this don't forget the
god killer armor right the god killer
armor was a suit of armor literally was
just kind of a giant robot that was
developed by the aspirants when they
originally went to war with the
celestials at the beginning of all of
creation that 25
000 foot tall piece of metal that was
controlled by Tony Stark he's also
created armors that allow him to tap
into Celestial energy right to basically
control a Celestial so he's well aware
of like how to deactivate these things
the problem is even those eternals who
were on the side of the X-Men are like
no because the reality of this is the
eternals see the celestials as like
their prophesized beings they don't
really agree with what this Celestial is
doing but they believe the best way to
overcome the Judgment of Earth is to
basically unify the world not to to
destroy the celestial itself but the
other part of this is their programming
remember eternals were created by
celestials and the results of this is
that the programming of the eternals is
that if a Celestial is on Earth and if
it is in danger they have to respond
it'll override their conscious thoughts
they'll literally just become robots
basically that have to run through and
save a Celestial and Destroy whatever
threat is standing against them and
that's kind of where you have these two
groups at odds Tony Stark thinks the
best possible thing is to destroy it
these eternals that are on the side of
the Avengers and the X-Men just refuse
to let that happen and so what you end
up doing is again jumping back to
krakowa where you have the X-Men
basically the most powerful mutants on
Earth who are standing against the hex
now remember one of the things that had
happened here in this story this whole
Avengers X-Men Eternal story is it
basically removed the eternals from just
being a handful of people who live on
earth and sometimes they get involved in
stuff and instead it turned them into a
whole society and one of the things that
we learned is that the hex are basically
the foot soldiers right they're like the
Special Forces guys of the eternals
there are enormous they're as big as
skyscrapers but like they're the ones
the eternals dispatch if things get
really really bad they have to go to war
and basically just run over some enemy
with overwhelming force and that's what
they have to do with krakowa because
some of the most powerful beings in
existence in the mutant population and
even just at all in Marvel Comics are in
krakowa so they have to approach
accordingly and so for the most part the
X-Men are literally fending off as best
they can and you even have Destiny who
can kind of see the future depending on
how far out she's looking who basically
meets with Emma Frost one of the most
powerful telepaths on Earth and is like
we need to basically have some kind of a
meeting but the reality here is Emma
Frost is like I mean we can but just
keep in mind like while we're
telepathically communicating we're also
fighting out here on the battlefield
Destiny basically says okay like I've
looked through the various options and
the only way for us to really come out
on top here is to launch a strike force
against the celestial because I've seen
what happens with this battle and if we
continue fighting like this we will lose
because there reality here is that every
time a mutant dies sure we can resurrect
ourselves but we basically have to be
fed information on what happened which
is secondary knowledge when an eternal
dies and they're resurrected by the
great machine they remember everything
right they remember every single thing
the experiences not only that they learn
they correct and they learn which means
they are going to get the upper hand on
us at some point in time this battle
cannot keep going on or they will kill
us all so launching this Strike Force is
the only way to do it now initially some
of them are kind of against it they're
like no no no we should not do that like
we should not launch a strike force and
try to destroy a Celestial because what
if it doesn't work like what if we what
if we try to blow up a Celestial and it
doesn't work he's gonna eradicate us all
but he's gonna kill us all just for
pissing him off and that's exactly the
the real concern to have here but the
other part of this is that some of the
mutants there are like but it's a risk
worth taking it's one worth doing and so
what you end up having is also Emma
Frost who says yes but we also have a
third option right here on krakowa we've
been Waging War or fighting against the
eternals and we can only fight for so
long but there is a force out there that
we have not tapped into yet that will
Ally themselves to our cause and that's
when you transition over to the krakowan
gates now remember only those who have a
mutant Gene can pass through the gates
and if there were any doubt in Marvel
Comics as to whether or not mutants are
a genetic offshoot of the deviants this
confirms it this solidifies that it's an
absolute truth because the other force
that Emma Frost was referring to are the
deviants themselves now one of the
things to keep in mind is that deviants
are as powerful as eternals under any
normal circumstance and depending on
what deviant you're talking about some
of them are more powerful than the
eternals so literally what you have is
Emma Frost who has basically made
Bargains with the deviance and an entire
Army of deviants come swollen to give
you guys perspective here remember at
the end of Avengers end game when you
had like just what was left of the
Avengers facing off of against like the
entire Army of Thanos and then all the
portals start opening up and basically
every superhero that we've ever seen in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe up to that
point all emerges at the same time
that's this that's basically what's
going on here and so what this does is
it drastically evens the odds but even
then the prophecy of Destiny remains we
cannot keep this battle going forever we
will inevitably lose and so what this
does is it switches back over to Tony
Stark and the eternals who are all
talking and Tony Stark is adamant about
this idea right like we have to find a
way to destroy the celestial but the
eternals simply won't won't let him and
in truth there's not really anything
Tony star can do to overcome the power
of the eternals right they're just way
too capable for him but in the midst of
all this discussion that's going on Mr
Sinister ever the manipulator and the
schemer ends up going over to one of the
computer panels and basically exposes a
node for a Celestial for the celestial
itself that if it's attacked with enough
energy will blow the whole thing up the
big concern here is if they do that what
kind of collateral damage are they
looking at right say for example they
detonate this Celestial say for example
this Celestial does get blown up by some
capacity millions of people in the
immediate vicinity will die but the
stance of Mr Sinister and even Tony
Stark to a degree is yes but future
billions will live right this is just
classic utilitarianism the needs of the
many outweigh the needs of the few
there's no argument about that there's
no discussion about that right like
that's just the way that it has to go
now again while Sinister is doing that
you actually end up having the eternals
realizing that there's a secondary
breach that's taken place here that
basically there's infiltrators some kind
of a strike team has arrived to their
location and is infiltrating the
celestial and that's basically because
of what's going on here because the the
celestial itself is now in immediate
danger by way of the actions of Mr
Sinister and the fact that Wolverine and
Jean Gray and those guys have arrived as
a strike force the programming takes
over and immediately the eternals turn
on the X-Men right those who are on the
scene and immediately tack them all
right like literally just it's like this
massive battle that takes place between
all of them right these most powerful
mutants that exist in Marvel Comics
alongside they are facing off against
these eternals the war is Extreme and it
is Harsh and that's the crazy thing at
the end of the day the X-Men and kind of
a last ditch effort are able to pull off
the attack and they destroy the
celestial which lets off this just
colossal atomic explosion that
eradicates millions of people and then
it ends then it stops and then suddenly
they realize the celestial's not gone
the celestial is there intact and that's
when Jean Gray comes to the realization
none of that actually happened there was
no colossal battle there was no major
war they were literally just shown by
this Celestial what would have happened
had they pulled off that attack this is
a strike against them because what it
means is that the population of Earth
would rather have destroyed millions of
people than find some peaceful
resolution to their conflict and so the
celestial doesn't necessarily use that
as a sign of judgment and say I judge
against the entirety of the human race
but what it does do is it literally says
okay it communicates with the entirety
of the world and it says everybody on
Earth you need to know this right I have
shown you every single person on the
face of the planet I have shown you what
this explosion would look like and I've
shown you the damage that it would do
you need to know that the people on this
earth right the the superheroes that
stand before you that they see
themselves as being gods above judgment
now all of you see that they are
mistaken your day ticks away you've got
24 hours to prove yourself remember that
was a statement that Celestial made you
have 24 hours to prove to me that you're
a race worth saving your day takes away
justify yourself that's a really really
important thing to understand because to
give you guys perspective here Jean Gray
is an immensely powerful telepath right
on a universal scale and the fact that a
Celestial was able to just trick her and
every other telepath on earth into
believing that what they were seeing was
real is a testament to its level of
power that's why I say this is the most
powerful Celestial to ever exist because
it's a combination of a multitude of
other celestials and so what it does is
it presents this scenario kind of
talking to us more as the reader than
anything else that it says more
judgments right thumbs down for the
woman of diamond for Emma Frost right
she's one that probably deserves a
thumbs down she's kind of a prick uh
thumbs up for the Deviant warlord right
thumbs down for the woman who walks
between Futures and the woman who walks
beside her right Destiny and her lover
Mystique that is going through each of
these individual people and is judging
in favor of them or against them now the
reality of this is that when it says I
will judge you individually and then I
will judge you as a collective what this
seems to indicate is that each person is
basically a tally thumbs up thumbs down
if there are more thumbs Downs across
the entire spectrum of the human race
and there are thumbs up everybody gets
destroyed right if there's more strikes
Against Humanity than for Humanity or if
there are more evil people in the world
than good people the world will end if
not the world will be allowed to
continue on and so what you have have is
this really really cool moment where you
basically have this discussion where
it's like okay they communicate with
Captain America and what Captain America
says is look guys like this whole thing
of us Waging War against each other this
is not gonna work if we keep on doing
this and we keep on fighting each other
that's going to do nothing but cause
problems what we need is someone who can
unify the world what we need is someone
who can bring the world together sun sun
sun he's like what we need is somebody
that can unify the war right God I love
this moment so much and so what this
does is it switches over to Cersei now
Cersei has this idea she ends up getting
with Jack Ablaze I remember Jack Ablaze
is an eternal who's an assassin but
knows how to get in and out of places
that people aren't normally supposed to
get in and out of what he does is
basically sneak her into the exclusion
Zone into the eternals prison and
Resurrection chamber right kind of
serving both purposes and as they get in
there there's this kind of conversation
where she's like yes like we need
somebody who's going to unify the
entirety of the Earth's population God
I'm so excited about this so what they
do is they make their their way to a
vault and when this person is like who's
there Cersei responds and says we're
here to break you out I think we're in
terrible trouble and I think you can
help someone to get the world singing
from the same hymn sheep now I know this
is eternal's business but some of us
have never been just eternals and I
thought that perhaps it's time for a
little of the old Avengers to assemble
and what we end up finding out is the
person she's talking to is Eros also
known as Star Fox for those of you guys
who don't know why this guy is so
important Eros has the ability to
manipulate the emotional states of
people what Heroes could do if his
powers are pushed to the Limit what he
could do is literally unify the entire
world even if it's against their will
the question you have to ask here is is
this the final straw because if Eros
comes along and he manipulates the world
into experiencing a sense of Harmony and
unification will the celestial see
through it will he know it's an illusion
or will they end up taking the powers of
Eros and using it on a Celestial which
begs the question can he even do that
now what this does is this initially
opens up with Captain America literally
at like Central Park right because
that's where the giant X-Men tree is
kind of emerged where you basically have
the the kind of field base right this is
where like the New York branch the X-Men
reside but people are here because
people are turning against the X-Men
population remember when it came to this
whole thing what's been going on behind
the scenes is that you have had the
X-Men and you've had the eternals and
you've had the The Avengers facing off
and kind of joining forces and then
turning against each other and so on and
so forth but the other big caveat here
is that the picture has been painted
that the mutants are why this is all
happening in the first place the other
part of this is that Humanity has always
had a fear of mutants and so as a result
in this time of desperation people look
to the mutants as being the cause of the
problem now the irony of all this is
Captain America is trying to talk
everybody down and that's one of the
things that we're told right the world
understands its Heroes cannot save them
they must be their own Heroes now they
must decide what hero means and we're
told by the celestial the tests are real
they cannot be sure the World shows its
true face and I watch Captain America
failed his test and praise others do not
do likewise so the man and the flag
tries to inspire people to not bludgeon
one another to death there's riots in
the streets riots in the country riots
in the homes riots and the hearts and
Captain America can't be everywhere and
this is really what the celestial was
hitting at right this is what the
progenitor was hitting at in the last
video that we did when it analyzed
Captain America and called him a failure
because in reality Captain America is a
hero that people look up to he's just
kind of The Sinner of the superhero
Community everybody respects him and the
average person knows who he is but in
times of desperation people will believe
what they want to believe and logic will
fly out the window in replace of an
emotional response people are angry and
they're scared and in in their anger and
fear they will become the worst versions
of themselves Captain America's speeches
and talking to them and trying to get
people to calm down it has no bearing
whatsoever so much so that people
actually turn against Captain America
because their thought is not Captain
America is here trying to like talk
reason into us and get us to you know
get to get the day to calm down instead
their Captain America is trying to stand
in the way of us destroying the thing
that will fix everything Captain America
wants us to die and in turn they turn on
him because of that and that's the crazy
thing because at this point we switch
our attention over to Eros now remember
Eros was the revelation of the person
the eternals reached out to to
effectively save them and Eros was a guy
who could do it remember Eros has the
ability to manipulate the emotions of
others he is a pure empath which means
he can live and he can can feel the
emotions of others in a variety of
different ways the funny thing about
this is Eros immediately counters the
point of Iron Man and Cersei and those
guys when their stance is Eros we need
you to use your power in order to
basically manipulate the emotions of
humanity to essentially instill peace on
a global scale and then the the
celestial will have to rule in our favor
eros's response that's ridiculous if I
do that this Celestia will see right
through it he will immediately know what
it is that's going on that he will see
that in the moment they are peaceful but
the reality is that in their heart of
hearts that they're still just as
terrible as they ever were what has to
be done here in order to bend the
celestial's will to our favor in order
to save our world is to somehow convince
this Celestial that in their heart of
hearts while it may not seem like it
people are inherently good and so what
and what we end up doing here is
actually kind of following the
progenitor as it goes through and starts
analyzing people one of the things it
says is that on his way home angry at
the world Tom passes two other angry men
who decide that he looks kind of Eastern
European and they have strong angry
opinions about that and so they beat him
up because of it the response that the
celestial had is Tom spits out a tooth
and fails to see the irony and so he
fails right the celestial looks to Luke
Cage and says Luke Cage is Mayor this is
his first Extinction event for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
when you originally had Kingpin who was
the mayor of New York during like the
entire just crazy situation where
Kingpin basically tried to take over the
city of New York Luke Cage ran against
him since basically attacking Kingpin
would offend would effectively make him
a martyr and would turn people to his
side so Luke Cage ran against him and
won and that's how Luke Cage became
mayor of New York if you guys are
curious about that I'll link the
playlist to that video down in the
description but nonetheless right the
progenitor says he poses as a man of the
press and asks him how do you judge your
performance as mayor and the response of
Luke Cage is a political answer ask me
tomorrow right kind of joking about it a
little bit and sort of easing the
tension and the response of the of the
progenitor is that is not an option to
take no stance is not an option and he
judges against Luke Cage he then
analyzes Thor and he says Thor Odin's
son fights the themix in orbit Mutual
powers like dueling Sons I observe him
closely I read his Hammer's inscription
and ascertain a Truth by definition he
must be worthy so Thor passes the test
and then he looks to Eros and the funny
thing about this is he doesn't pass
judgment on Eros instead he watches as
Eros just listens to other people Heroes
literally travels around the world and
hears people's stories listens to what
they have to say and then just absorbs
that information but the celestial then
turns to Kamala Khan right to Miss
Marvel and he says I appear before
Kamala Khan as Captain Marvel offering
her and her family a chance to leave the
planet escape this and join the secret
higher League of Marvel heroes she
pummels me and demands I tell her what I
did with the real Carol she cannot see
my hand move in her huge fist but she
passes and I vanish now the cool thing
about this and this is what's so ironic
is it's not just the progenitor judging
superheroes it's the progenitor judging
everybody and so one of the things he
says is a woman named Katrina leaves her
hotel room on her way to a rally she's
50 meters down the corridor before she
realizes she forgot a tip she looks at
the distance back no she's late and
decides not to go back and deliver a tip
and Carries On and the progenitor says I
appear to her in the form of her dead
Aunt with a thumbs down she's mortified
and she asks what did I do and I simply
just don't tell her time and time again
it's the same thing it appears to trial
Xavier as Legion and says I need to talk
Charles Xavier does what he's always
done which is blow off his son and the
celestial judges against him the
celestial continues to watch Eros the
celestial judges the starbread judges in
favor of her the celestial judges a
woman named Daniela as Daniella watches
all the footage going on and in that
moment with daniela's relationship with
her mother being strained at the very
best she decides she needs to be there
for her mom she goes home the celestial
judges in her favor now one of the funny
things that happens here is the
celestial appears to Doctor Doom now you
guys know how Doctor Doom is right you
guys know how Victor Von Doom is right
literally real Celestial appears and
says I appear to Victor Von Doom and
give him a simple challenge say that
Reed Richards is smarter than you and
you will pass he laughs and then laughs
some more and then leaves he passes
himself I concur like literally Dr
Doom's like I'm not taking your stupid
test I decide that I pass and the
celestial's like I mean oh okay you know
but it's again one of those great
moments because then it appears to
Daredevil right and this is one of those
interesting things because remember
Daredevil's Catholic he's a man of faith
and one of the things that Celestial
says is Matt Murdock dresses as a devil
and tries to stop the streets from
becoming Health he is a man with a firm
moral code which he has violated time
and time over I appear with a crown of
thorns and a downturned thumb Beneath
The Mask Matt Murdoch weeps he says I
know yet he carries on and that's the
crazy thing it's just one of these
amazing and beautiful moments that goes
on here and so ultimately after
everything that's happened the celestial
continues his judgments of various
people and and even superheroes across
the world but then you have Eros who
appears to a coming together of the
United Nations and he literally says
okay for all of you out there here's the
thing to understand and it's really him
learning this Humanity will not come
together just because it's the right
thing to do it's not in the nature of
people to do that the nature of humanity
is to be destructive it's to ruin things
destroy things not necessarily because
it's ingrained in our evolutionary
biology but because it's just what we've
been doing for so long drawing
boundaries over pieces of land to
differentiate between one nation and
another one human being looking at
another insane because of your skin
color or your gender or what have you
you're different from me and that makes
you bad just things along those lines
right as primitive as those ideologies
are Eros came to the realization that
Humanity has been doing it for so long
it doesn't know anything else and so
using that to his to his benefit he
approaches the United Nations and says
if you won't come together because it's
the right thing to do then maybe I can
just bribe you to do so right as it
stands right now the X-Men and the
eternals have technology that you as
normal humans simply just don't have not
only that if you are willing to come
together and bring your countries
together and unify in a way that will
save our world then we will also Grant
you Celestial technology not on a
massive scale but something that will
basically help to Usher inhumanity into
a golden age because the reality is we
as eternals have had this technology for
a pretty lengthy amount of time and for
the most part our unwillingness to share
it with you has in a lot of ways been a
failure we could have actually turned
Earth into a golden age but we just
never really did for any number of
reasons the X-Men have recently
discovered this power and they've kept
it selfishly and the celestial power is
out there for Humanity to be used we
will guide you we won't just give it to
you arbitrarily but we will give you the
tools you need to move beyond your
current primitive standpoint of drawing
artificial boundaries that are literally
guaranteed by virtue of just yellow
marks along the road and in turn we will
help you become better and so that's one
of the ideas here is that hopefully it
will lead to a unification of humanity
but the other concern here and the
bigger thing they have to deal with is
Uranus because remember Uranus is one of
the original eternals this guy's so
powerful he showed up on Mars a planet
full of Omega Level mutants and
eradicated pretty much everybody right
within one hour this guy's on just a
whole different level of power and he's
basically being used by Druid who's the
current leader of the eternals and the
one that really instigated this war in
the first place and so the issue the
eternals have to deal with is their
numbers are fractured their numbers are
split they can't just launch an attack
against Druid because he's the leader of
the eternals it'd be like just
assassinating some kind of world leader
you can't do that right because it'll
turn the other eternals against them and
in fact it'll actually incite a civil
war among the eternals what they need is
for Druid to screw up to make a mistake
to do something that will basically lead
to the other eternals losing faith in
him and then voting him out as the prime
Eternal and voting somebody in his stead
but that's the concern when it comes to
dealing with Uranus because their fear
here is that what if Druid will unleash
Uranus on Earth itself what could he
possibly do like imagine the amount of
damage he could inflict here now the
crazy thing about this and the funny
thing about this is that the entire
concern with regards to voting for
druick is limited to the existing
celestials right they can at any point
in time initiate a vote of no confidence
right they can't at any point in time
the eternals can come along and say we
call for a vote of no confidence in
druitt and we want to elect a new leader
the issue is if they do that their
numbers are split almost perfectly even
if they were to launch that vote what it
would do is it would lead to effectively
the entirety of the the Eternal
landscape staying exactly as it is right
now because those who voted for druitt
are going to vote for him again those
who voted against him are going to vote
against him again there won't be any
real change what they need is somebody
who can turn turn the tide and so what
happens here is that druig ultimately
summons the unimod where he does this as
a means to launch a psychic attack
against the Omega Level telepath on
Earth in the hopes of annihilating all
of them but in his Hubris in doing this
and overlooking and overplaying his hand
what this does is it allows a field team
to infiltrate the exclusion zone right
remember the exclusion zone is the great
machine of the eternals everything that
makes the eternals who they are is is
literally confined to that including the
ability to quote unquote hack into the
unimod and that's exactly what happens
that when the defense systems of the
unimind are effectively down this allows
the mutants to enter into the mind of
the unimind itself it allows the
telepath to enter in directly now this
is a major change when it comes to the
nature of mutants in Marvel Comics
something that I want to establish here
is that yes mutants and deviants do
possess similar genes and basically
mutants are descendants of deviants
hence the reason why deviants were able
to pass through the Cocoon Gates because
the genetic material of deviants and
mutants is close enough that there are
distant relatives essentially right
mutants are the result of humans with a
deviant Gene the difference here is that
under any normal Circumstance the
unimind is confined to eternals only the
mutants are not eternals here so under
any normal Circumstance the mutants
would never be able to enter into the
unimind and then vote for a new Prime
Eternal what's happened here is that by
hacking the firewall of the unamine and
in turn allowing other Minds to enter
into it that what this does is with the
vote being cast it cannot be done it's
irrevocable but Judah can't say no no no
they can't vote because they're mutants
right there it doesn't count once the
vote is made the vote is guaranteed
there's no conceivable way to undo it or
to change it it doesn't matter and so as
a result of that when the mutants vote
they vote in favor of Eros but what it
does is it changes the landscape in that
Eros is voted as the new Prime Eternal
the problem with this is that moment
moments before the vote is cast Druid in
an act of desperation unleashes Uranus
on Earth with the belief that Uranus in
his promise would basically solve the
problem by eliminating the mutant
population and ensuring that the the
forces of druig would remain in control
what Uranus did was abandon the promise
so the vote went through the result of
this is that Eros becomes the new Prime
Eternal and Uranus is now free on
Olympia and even free on Earth the
reason why this matters is because
remember Uranus can tap into the Armory
of the eternals in doing so quite
literally portals start opening all over
the world and just massive beings of
astronomical power begin to show up
because of the forces of the power of
Uranus to essentially summon them now
the crazy thing about this is that no
one really knows what to do here right
Iron Man is like okay we have to find a
way to essentially utilize the very
weapons of Uranus against him right what
we need is someone out there let me tell
you something what we need is somebody
out there that has the ability to seize
control of the very metals that Uranus
uses for his guns and arms and Armament
and all that stuff and as Uranus is
gearing up and Uranus is prepping all
these massive weapons to start opening
fire and unleashing just Hell Fire on
the on the world itself the master of
magnetism appears son Magneto mixes
returns baby yes remember Magneto is one
of the people who was thought to have
been killed by Uranus on Mars this guy
right the power of Magneto his heart was
ripped out of his chest this guy used
his own control over magnetism to keep
the blood flowing in his body to give
himself an artificial heart so he could
continue fighting and this guy is
incensed this guy has eight kinds of
piss and so when like when the deal is
made right like when Tony Stark hacks
into the systems into the the entire
Armory of of Uranus and he's like
Magneto are you there right the response
man you know is yes I'm ready whenever
you are right like like Tony Stark opens
the portals to the various weapons right
these just massive energy cannons that
that Uranus has and then literally all
the Cannons end up targeting uranos with
the help of Magneto and in that moment
Magneto's just like fire and then just
the whole thing just goes off and
incinerates Uranus on the spot just
kills Uranus right there on the spot now
one of the things you remember eternals
never die they always get resurrected so
the result of this is that yes Uranus is
destroyed in the moment the momentary
issue is quelled he's sent back to his
containment cell where he starts to
reconstruct himself but lest we forget
what it was Magneto did do not forget
here when it comes to mutants they can
always be resurrected so long as they're
in the database but in order to truly
become a member of oracco society that
Magneto deleted himself from the
database of krakawa meaning if he dies
there's no coming back and Magneto dies
he had just enough energy to basically
keep himself alive right just enough
power to keep himself there and in that
moment he ultimately passes on right he
ultimately ends up dying and so as a
result of this the progenitor's
celestial monitoring everything right
literally says this is the moment
Magneto could weakened he could call out
to his old friend who would still save
him I listen and there is nothing he
does not betray his promise to the
iroquo people he truly is a guy who's
maintaining his role in araka right
maintaining the deal that was made he's
not a betrayer of his own word and in
turn the progenitor says he sees me as I
slip away I take on the form of the one
he thought he lost she smiles and waves
approvingly if all were like him there
would be no need for men like him but
look this is of interest to me and what
you end up having is Eros who approaches
the progenitor Celestial and the
response of Eros is this look I have
traveled the world and I have talked to
all different manner of people I have
spoke to them I've heard their words
I've made deals with them and the
reality here is that we as people can be
better we can improve we can be more
capable but we can't do it in a day we
need more than a day by tomorrow we can
become better and that's when the
progenitor is like it's time right I do
not address the world I have spoken
enough I have watched enough and I have
judged enough and I have decided you
have all lived enough if you had a
million years you'd never do enough
you'll always be better tomorrow
tomorrow things will be different
tomorrow you will improve it's always
tomorrow it's always tomorrow it's
always tomorrow and he says but you
don't realize that one day tomorrow
would run out and the progenitor judges
against the entirety of humanity and
starts eradicating all life on Earth but
the thing about this is that in this
comic and in this story The God
Celestial in the last video that we did
had examined the real heart of hearts
when it came to individual people it
looked at a combination of how they see
themselves how they see the world their
actions what they truly believe all
those different things and it judged
against humanity because it made the
decision that Humanity just simply made
the world a crappy place because
Humanity in and of itself is really
self-destructive selfish different
things like that and what the god
Celestial does is looking at Humanity as
it exists in the Marvel Universe then it
looks at Humanity as being a group
whereby there is more negativity than
there is positivity humanity is
inherently worse than it is beneficial
now the funny thing about this is that
to a degree the god Celestial is not
really judging objectively and this
comes by way of a girl named Jada who
meets with Captain America that Steve
Rogers was one of the first people to be
judged by the god Celestial and in
looking at Steve Rogers basically came
up with this idea or came up with this
argument that you have positioned
yourself you want thrust into this role
you positioned yourself as being kind of
the moral focal point of the superhero
Community right you're Captain America
everybody rallies around you you have
failed in your role it's almost to a
degree a kind of meta textual critique
of America here in the real world right
like a Beacon of Hope and light in the
world and a task that we've kind of
failed at and that's the argument that
it creates here with Captain America but
the reality here is it is a skewed
judgment because there comes a point
when Captain America is talking to Jada
who's just a regular person out there
and it's one of those things where we
end up finding out that she had lost her
daughter when she was younger and
literally is just angry at the world
because of it and in fact she's angry at
the people she knows because they
survived where her daughter died now
that's usually a normal reaction when it
comes to like losing someone Close To
You Right losing a parent especially if
you're parent who's lost a child you're
surrounded by people who survived and
the question you probably find yourself
asking is why are they alive why did my
child have to die why couldn't one of
them have died instead or something
along those lines as if it's some kind
of divine judgment that says that like
somebody's got to die today and it might
as well be your daughter right like well
why couldn't it be that person over
there it's not logical it's 100
emotional but it's the nature of people
and it's one of the things where when
she has this conversation with Captain
America he's kind of like but you should
be spending time with your family right
we're here in the final moments of
Humanity's existence you should be
spending that time with your family it's
him trying to inspire her and that's
where you really start to realize that
the Judgment of the celestial is a
skewed judgment here because when you
look at Captain America for what he
truly is he is inspiring he is a person
that's able to motivate and drive people
to become better what you end up running
into is basically people who aren't
really able to look at that inspiration
and see it for what it is and find
themselves blinded by their own
political views or their own life
experiences or their own moral compass
or whatever ever happens to be that
basically keeps them thinking small and
acting small and viewing the world in
relation to themselves now of course in
the midst of this conversation
Nightcrawler simply appears and says Hey
so uh we're basically going to try to
find a way to save the world even though
the world hates us and the world judges
us as mutants ah but do you want to
become a part of it
and so what ends up happening is Captain
America kind of has this realization
where he basically tells Nightcrawler
teleport me to the celestial and when
that happens have Jean Gray use her
telepathic powers to broadcast the
entire situation to the world and what
Captain America says in speaking to this
Celestial is he says I've stood before
tyrants before they've all been so sure
that it's all over they were all as sure
as you are I was there in 1940 and
people thought it was over heroism is
not about strength it's about Not Giving
in and the truth is it's not over as
long as any of us are standing the world
can hear me know this we are all
Avengers now a symbol and avenge now of
course Captain America is annihilated in
front of everybody by the celestial but
the world sees this broadcast and that's
the unifying factor of Captain America
the question then becomes how successful
would we be if we launched a strike
against the the god Celestial itself now
the Turtles chime in and the eternals
are like lest we forget the nature of
our programming if we attack a Celestial
we'll be overtaken by it right our
programming will take over and will in
turn start attacking you guys it's
exactly what happened before but they
also found a workaround what they ended
up doing was basically kind of lowering
their psychic firewalls right if their
programming is ingrained into their DNA
because in Marvel Comics eternals are
not robots but if they're if their mind
is more or less programmed with this
idea that no Celestial can be harmed in
the presence of an eternal then what
would happen if a powerful enough
telepath were capable of overriding that
that if they lowered their their mental
protection right their mental blocks and
someone like Jean Gray were to seize
control of them and that programming
were to kick in is Jean Gray powerful
enough to override it and the answer to
that question is absolutely she is and
not just Jean Gray the other telepaths
and so what ends up happening here is
that all forms of disagreement are cast
aside by The eternals Who were here as
well as the X-Men and the remaining
Avengers and what this does is it allows
the group to unify now for the telepaths
they seize control of the eternals and
what that does is it allows them to
control the eternals essentially but to
also keep out the programming so it will
allow the eternals to attack the
celestials and when I say the eternals I
mean all of them even the hex right just
these ridiculously huge and Powerful
eternals it allows them to control them
all and so what you end up getting is
this unified force of the Avengers and
the X-Men and the eternals all of whom
launch their attack against the
celestial and it's the funniest thing
because literally this Celestial says
they are Earth's Best hope mortal power
against a star God the buzz of
ballistics cannot hurt me however it
does distract it allows the hex to get
close each one of the Stepford cacus who
are basically clones of Emma Frost each
one of the step for Cuckoos drives one
of the soldier heads mother Emma takes
mother region X they are machines
designed to fight Cosmic Predators such
as myself their attack compromises my
counter-attack leading me open for
reposit I am a god appropriately they
unleash hell yet all of this is prologue
the hammer is still to come Earth's
Mightiest strike is one their target is
exposed they are a metaphorical Hammer
the final blow is from one more literal
right the hammer of Thor himself I am
impressed I see so many brought together
but I have already finished my judgment
what God would I be if I backed out now
yes Thor is worthy but the world is not
I make every part of Thor unworthy his
skin slows from his body in revulsion
star brand Burns Phoenix Burns Jean Gray
Burns Exodus Burns phosphorus fast they
are all gone it's basically like a total
Annihilation here this is something that
I want to point out is that these Heroes
getting close enough to this guy
Celestial and being close enough to
attack it it was him allowing it to
happen if anything it was actually him
just kind of toying with them allowing
them to believe they could come that
close to Victory allowing them to
believe that they ever even stood a
chance in the first place but the
reality is none of them ever did he
kills all of them all of them are
completely annihilated by the celestial
like we're talking about Carol Danvers
we're talking about Spider-Man right
Thor the whole nine yards the heaviest
hitters in Marvel Comics from a variety
of different places are all being
completely and totally annihilated and
there's nothing they can do to stop this
and so it literally says I will burn the
cities and I will burn the Seas I will
burn the Earth and all creatures of the
Earth the passengers of this ship
represent more wealth than the rest of
the planet combined the experimental
engines prepare to engage sites set on a
new blue-green Eden they think they can
escape my judgment no one of the things
that I also want to point out here is
this is how celestials work so the way
this normally happens right usually it's
erisham the judge that will judge
against the world when hiroshim judges
against the world then another Celestial
will cleanse the planet quite literally
they'll turn it into a burning sender
just floating through space but then the
gardener Celestial will come in and
actually start planting new Seeds of
Life on the world and it'll basically
start to grow again right life will be
able to start all over again and that's
really what the god Celestial is doing
here right it's making this
determination that what it's going to do
is annihilate all life on Earth and then
start allowing Earth to basically start
developing new life and hopefully
Humanity won't screw up again when
Humanity inevitably re-emerges if it
even emerges in its current form and so
that's one of those things where it's
like we don't know exactly how this will
turn out but everything is being
cleansed and sanitized it's all being
completely and totally destroyed the
crazy thing about it is even the god
Celestial tells the Earth it's time to
die and the Earth itself lashes back at
the god Celestial and simply just
refuses to allow itself to be destroyed
but the truth about this is that when it
comes to all these Heroes who have been
annihilated precious few survive
something like five of them made it out
in one piece most everybody else was
completely eradicated but remember the
other problem here is that when the war
between the X-Men and the eternals first
broke out the Jack of Blades had
infiltrated cocoa and in doing that had
destroyed their ability or at least most
of their ability to resurrect anybody
from the dead using the krakowan
resurrection system and so because of
that what you have now is just a handful
of eggs that can be used by the five to
bring back anybody who's died and so the
effort to do this is really confined to
who do we bring back now the response of
somebody like Exodus is we have to bring
back Cyclops Cyclops is the field leader
of the X-Men he's the guy that was
literally the one that would take us
into battle take us into conflict right
he's our version of Captain America but
the response of Nightcrawler any even
the response everybody else is no that's
not who the world needs right now the
world does not need like Cyclops the
world does not need him right the other
part of this is that when they had
initially launched their strike against
the celestial they had consulted Destiny
right because remember Destiny can see
the future and the closer to the present
day or the present moment that she's
predicting the more accurate she is
right so if she predicts or says here's
what's going to happen in five minutes
it's gonna be way more accurate than if
she says here's what's supposed to
happen in 500 years but when they
consulted her and they talked to her her
stance was yes your attack on the
celestial can work but only with a few
modifications and so what they did is
they held some of their number back with
the intention of launching yet another
strike force to infiltrate the celestial
now with our initial Strike Force was
done for the purpose of exposing some
kind of weakness that would allow the
superheroes to destroy the celestial
that doesn't work they already know that
fails so they have to have some other
plan in place we don't know the exact
details of it but basically it's Jacob
blades who leads the Strike Team into
the celestial itself the problem with
this is that when they arrive the
celestial as you would expect
immediately picks up on the fact that
they're there even though they have a
cloaking system and it makes perfect
sense right I mean it's very difficult
to fool a Celestial using something like
telepathy or just a basic cloaking
device because celestials are just so
astronomically powerful but in order to
fool the celestial into believing that
Jack of Blades is the only one who's
actually there that what Jack ablades
does is appear to the celestial and
literally just make some kind of
offhanded remark right like I'll be
seeing you and draws the attention of
the celestial which annihilates Jack but
it seems to lead the celestial to
believe that Jack was the only one who
was there that's actually not the case
but the thing about this is that when
you pick back up with essentially this
Resurrection process the members of the
five who were able to bring people back
there's this debate going on between
Exodus and Nightcrawler that's still
raging right The Stance of Exodus we
have to bring back Cyclops we can't
bring back anybody else but but again
what ends up happening is Nightcrawler
says no this is the guy we have to bring
back and the response of Exodus is this
is heresy right you we cannot use it's
against the rules of krakowa to use
these eggs to bring him back it goes
against everything that we have and The
Stance of Nightcrawler is no it simply
just goes against our customs right the
Only Rule that we have when it comes to
humanity is kill no man right do not
start a war between human beings and
like the mutant population but the other
reason why this is so important is
because he says what are Customs if not
just habits that we have that a lot of
people take part in right getting
together on Sunday for dinner is a habit
but it becomes a custom because it's
something that like the entire family
does but the reality is as long as we
live we have to try something new that's
what we do Cyclops is a great leader but
he's not who the earth needs right now
and so using the power of Resurrection
what they end up doing is bringing this
person back and when that happens in one
of the greatest moments in Marvel Comics
Captain America's shield comes smashing
through the mutant Resurrection system
now the question you have to ask here is
this is this Steve Rogers as we knew him
is this Steve Rogers with potential
enhancements if Steve Rogers a guy with
powers now what kind of Captain America
are we looking at here because lest we
forget whenever mutants are resurrected
they're always resurrected based on how
they existed before right meaning like
their minds were backed up and while
Captain America is not a mutant remember
you have Proteus here who's the one
resurrecting people meaning Proteus can
modify the DNA structure of anybody he
resurrects if there was a request that
was made we need to give Captain America
more Powers we need to give him a
combination of all the X-Men's powers or
all the Avengers powers or make him
equal to the celestial in terms of power
presumably Proteus could potentially do
that that's the question you have to ask
here is this just human Captain America
or is it some thing more but the thing
about this is that where you did have
the progenitor Celestial that basically
annihilated everybody there are some who
made it out alive specifically those
individuals who were actually inside of
the progenitor Celestial itself of
course Iron Man Jean Gray those
individual guys now the thing about this
is that it really is in the most true
definition a coming together of the
Avengers the X-Men and the eternals and
some of these guys have actually been
both for example Wolverine has been both
a X-Man and an Avenger he's never been
an eternal but nonetheless right their
goal here is the same as it was before
to find some way to bring the progenitor
Celestial down except this time it's not
the same right previously when they lost
a Strike Team it was to try to find a
weak point and destroy that weak point
obviously that failed because of the
fact that they were dealing with a being
of just cosmic power so somehow getting
inside of it and trying to find a way to
deactivate it or end it from the inside
out is seemingly the only way to pull
that off now the irony behind all this
and this is one of those things where
Marvel's kind of changing it either for
the story or because it's just the
future nature of things is when they get
inside of the celestial itself so the
interior or the insides of a Celestial
have been depicted in different ways in
Marvel Comics in different instances
they've said that celestials are just
beings composed of pure energy on the
inside in other instances celestials are
actually beings you can enter into the
reality here and this current depiction
of the inside of a Celestial has kind of
been this way ever since Mr Sinister had
first entered into the dreaming
Celestial in Marvel Comics back in the
day so it's kind of the standard they're
going with and will likely continue with
for quite some time but the important
thing here is that once they're in there
they start to realize that the celestial
literally has an antibody system right
it has what amounts to human white blood
cells insides of it or organisms inside
of it that are designed to basically
Force out any kind of external Factor
that's not supposed to be there in this
instance those individual guys now the
most logical question to ask here is if
this is a being of unfathomable power
Why didn't it just incinerate them while
they're inside and the answer to that is
comic book Logic the necessity of being
able to tell the story so what this does
is of course it leads to the X-Men the
eternals and the Avengers all kind of
bailing out as fast as they can but
these different antibodies end up
adhering themselves to Tony Stark and
that's when Tony Stark goes to this
really really cool process because he
almost kind of finds himself in this
cave so to speak and sees the body of ho
Jensen and then he's immediately
attacked by the Iron Man suit mark one
right like the first suit of armor that
he ever made as primitive as it was
comparing to the kind of stuff that he
has now and it's one of those things
where he's sort of taunted by it right
where even the suit goes as far as to
say look at your legacy Tony look at
what you've done you keep building suits
people keep dying I am the end result of
your efforts to build some being out
there that can really be a testament to
what you're capable of and I've
annihilated pretty much all the
superheroes that you know your legacy
Tony Stark is a legacy of death and
ultimately it's one of those things
where Tony Stark initially brushes it
off but then he starts getting these
hard-on Visions like the death of
Captain America and that's one of the
cool moments here because this is in a
lot of ways kind of The Life and Times
of Tony Stark or this sort of depiction
of the people that Tony Stark has in
some form or fashion led to the death of
not not directly but the thing about
this is it's kind of a reliving that
moment where even Captain America pops
up and it's like I could be dead already
I could be dead again and you may as
well have killed me and it's really just
this instance where this Celestial is
putting Iron Man through the paces and
saying you created me you're the one
that frankensteined me together it was
your idea this kind of goes directly
into Christopher cantwell's Iron Man run
which was just a phenomenal story but
basically it was a story where Tony
Stark ended up becoming what was called
the iron God where he basically got
galactus's power but for a time Tony
Stark was the most powerful being in the
universe outside of like the super high
level Cosmic entities right eternity
Infinity those guys but in that story he
had actually killed James Rhodes and
pretty much all of his allies at least
as far is a space Friends team but he's
kind of taunted by that right like look
at your legacy Tony Stark you killed me
right James Rhodes kind of appearing as
War Machine and of course he ended up
kind of setting him back but then he's
basically shown or kind of presented
with Ragnarok right now when it comes to
Marvel Comics Ragnarok appears in two
different forms there's the Ragnarok
event which is basically the death of
all the asgardians right the foretold
prophecy of how the asgardians will die
and then there was Ragnarok in the form
of the Thor robot that Iron Man had
created using a strand of Thor's hair
and kind of cloned him and create a sort
of cyborg in the process but during the
original Civil War event when Ragnarok
was originally presented to the world it
killed Bill Foster and so Tony Stark is
kind of confronted with that like your
legacy is one of death and destruction
your legacy is one where people end like
literally it says you tried it with me
and you saw what happened you never
learn but the truth right now a God was
needed you were the iron God and you
gave it up if you were still the the
iron God you could have fought this
Celestial returned all to life undone
all whoa if only you had held it
together for a few more weeks now one of
the things that I also want to point out
here is that for these different
circumstances that Tony Stark is being
presented with Tony Stark is presenting
himself in a humble way he's not
ingratiating himself but he's accepting
his faults and accepting his his
failures like in response to the idea of
him having been the iron God having had
the power of Galactus his response is it
was too much for me and it's too much
for anyone and even here it's kind of
stated you're right you could have never
held it together men like you are slowly
killing the planet at least this cuts to
the chase you're an addict always will
be you're off booze and now you're
addicted to saving the world bigger risk
bigger High how fine can you cut it
eventually you were always going to push
it too close that it's really one of
those things where it's like it's always
he's always going from one addiction to
another addiction right it's the nature
of Tony Stark in Marvel Comics and so as
one of those things where following that
he's presented with the Incredible Hulk
this of course is a homage to the
original sin's story for those of you
guys who never read that one of the
things that had gone on there is that
there was a the original project that
had led to Bruce Banner becoming the
Incredible Hulk was actually a joint
venture between Tony Stark and banner
and I'm a little fuzzy on the details
but the long and short of it is that
seemingly Tony Stark was aware of what
was going on that basically this gamma
explosion could potentially have
disastrous results and could actually
lead to something of you know something
like this happening to Banner or at
least affecting him in some way but
because of that when Banner had learned
that truth he blamed Iron Man for the
fact that he became Hulk in the first
place that's what this is It's kind of
the really Iron Man being Revisited by
all his sins but it's also Iron Man
having to come to terms in his battle
against the entirety of the superhero
Community right to face his own demons
is to face the superhero Community
because time and time again Iron Man and
has done nothing but in a lot of ways
fail the superhero community and so what
ends up happening is one of the things
that he's forced to endure is the death
of his parents right watching his
parents die but the selection even says
that it says hey some bad news here with
Whitney Frost shaped exceptions you're
attracted to parental figures who
provide a strong moral compass because
yours is absolutely whacked I wonder
where it comes from and the reality here
is that it comes from Howard and Maria
Stark Maria Stark kind of tried to do
her best to a degree but Howard Stark
was exceedingly hard on Tony and it was
one of those things where it was always
like you can be better you have to be
better now this is where the the history
gets a little murky because if you go
back and you read Kieran gillen's run uh
the secret origin of Tony Stark you
learned that Tony's actually adopted by
Howard and Maria and their biological
son is Arno who is every bit as smart as
Howard wanted him to be due to some
genetic modifications and tampering the
whole Arnold Stark thing just kind of
seems to have taken a background and
just sort of been wiped Away by time
more or less in Marvel Comics it is
haven't really told any stories about
him but the important distinction here
is that in place of Arno Tony was raised
by Howard and whether or not Arno still
even a part of the equation the fact
remains Howard was always hard on Tony
he was very much a perfectionist you can
be better so be better right being like
like trying your best is not good enough
be the best right Like Only Fools make
mistakes and so it's one of those things
where in the end you have this amazing
realization because Tony Stark kind of
comes clean in terms of why he even does
what he does in the first place he says
he says I always hoped it was an
accident or an assassination that people
claim that it was or that Mom and Dad
faked their deaths or something that's
what orphans do we make up stories that
give a bit of drama right they give a
reason to why this happened but in the
end it was just a car crash people die
for no reason at all and in response the
celestial says you are mistaken there
was a reason they died because a machine
failed them if only they had been in a
better machine a machine that could have
protected them in this hell world and
that is the source of why Tony Stark
does what he does because in the end he
initially tries to blow off the entirety
of the of the celestial and saying like
I've got work to do right I don't really
have time for for any of this nonsense
and the response of the celestial is to
basically appear as Howard Stark and to
say people die son I was a terrible
father we wanted you so badly and then
when we had you I still wasn't great we
did a number on you and then we left you
we had so much we wanted to tell you and
share and show yet you keep on going he
says I wouldn't have most people
wouldn't have a broken machine keeps on
ticking anyway you're too hard on
yourself you pass I couldn't be prouder
of you because it's Tony Stark
confessing to the celestial that's why
he does what he does it's why he builds
such Advanced machines that's why he
builds Iron Man suits it's like he goes
on these crazy campaigns from time to
time where he always has to be better
because because it's one of those
retroactive things if he builds a better
Iron Man suit this time he can save his
mom and dad right building the most
advanced Iron Man suit he can possibly
can is like basically building a better
car so his mom and dad wouldn't have
died he's Chasing Ghosts there's no way
for him to keep that from happening I
mean I guess maybe he could invoke time
travel but that's never really been a
major part of his story that's been
explored and honestly I'd be kind of
curious to see what would happen if it
was but the reality here is the death of
Howard and Maria Stark played a
significant role in The Life and Times
of Tony because them dying in a car
crash was just that and so once it's all
said and done he kind of emerges from
this quote-unquote antibody cocoon if
you want to call it that but basically
brought about by the eternals and the
the X-Men and the rest of the Avengers
and so on and so forth and the thing
about it is that he talks about how he
met his dad and his dad told him like
I'm proud of you you've always become
the person that I thought you would and
that sort of thing so even if only on an
emotional level reconciling with his own
father and where it's initially brushed
off by Mr Sinister the response of Iron
Man is no like you don't get it it was
test me and if it's still testing me
it's still testing us and if it's still
testing us it means we have a chance to
win we have a chance to Stave off the
destruction of the planet it's when that
clock reaches zero when the hand gets to
midnight then that's when we panic but
for right now we're five minutes from
Annihilation which means we have five
minutes to save every living thing on
Earth so one of the things to remember
is that when you have the kind of unity
Squad which is basically what this is
Iron Man Jean Gray you do have like
Logan and like some of the other
eternals who are here this is their
second attempt at a strike force and
this is what we talked about before the
first attempt at the strike force was to
basically hit like what was essentially
the kill switch for the progenitor
Celestial this one is more of trying to
find a way to destroy it from the inside
out now initially they thought they
could be sneaky and get on board but the
funny thing about this and this just
shows the level of power the progenitor
Celestial has and its lack of concern is
that even when they're inside of it it's
still testing them so the last video
that we did focused on the test of Iron
Man of Tony Stark testing his character
to see whether or not he's worthy of
surviving with Jean Gray it's much the
same way here the funny thing about this
is that when this goes down as they're
making their way to the heart of the
celestial so to speak that Jean Gray is
able to help them deal with some of the
forces to a degree but then her test
begins and she suddenly yanked back to
the Xavier school for gifted youngsters
now this is one of the cool moments and
there is a little bit of History here so
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with Jean Gray when she initially
appeared in Marvel Comics she literally
showed up in X-Men issue number one and
was kind of our eyes and ears as the
reader meaning she was given a tour of
the entire grounds by Professor Xavier
she was told what the X-Men were what
their purpose is why they do what they
do that kind of thing but there was a
story that was written later on by Chris
Claremont in Bizarre Adventures Issue
Number 27 and what this did is it
actually told us Xavier had been
watching Jean Gray for quite some time
that this was actually included later on
in the X-Men Origins Jane gray one shot
but the way the story was originally
written is that when Jean Gray was alone
girl her friend Annie died and when that
happened she kind of sent out this sort
of telepathic shock wave like an SOS
right like a telepathic scream of
Anguish if you want to call it that
Xavier picked up on it but so did the
Phoenix force and both of them basically
watched Jean Gray the Phoenix Force
watched her knowing that Jean Gray was
the kind of person who would eventually
become the host of The Phoenix and
Xavier watched her because he realized
how powerful she was telepathically and
telekinetically and so this is why she
was originally brought on the X-Men team
now unlike what we saw in the Iron Man
one shot that we covered in the last
video where it's strictly confined in
the mind of Iron Man this one actually
shows us what other people are doing
right so it's kind of a little bit of a
jump back and forth but the reality is
for the most part they come to the
consensus this is Jean Gray's test Jean
Gray has to be the one to endure it but
there will be a kind of stepping in that
does take place but the celestial
continuing to prod her mind showing her
these parts of herself and forcing her
to confront these aspects that she had
largely wanted to get rid of it
basically takes her mind to the quiet
Council when the they were initially
trying to decide what they were going to
do with the progenitor Celestial and the
reality here is the discussion as it
took place was a discussion of okay
what's best for the world how do we
handle this so on and so forth the real
meat and potatoes of this discussion was
that the cry Council didn't really care
how their actions impacted normal
mutants who were out there or even just
regular human beings because ever since
the process of Resurrection was Mastered
by mutants they've become very Cavalier
with the lives of mutants and this
manifests in the way in which the
discussion is presented to Jean Gray if
we succeed it will almost certainly kill
Untold millions of distinctly
unfashionable dressed humans but perhaps
it's still a worthwhile use of our time
of course we won't tell the foot
soldiers no need for the little people
to know anybody object please raise your
hand and it's one of those things where
it's like Jean Gray you have blood on
your hands right and that's the crazy
thing is because her response is no I
left the quiet counsel because I wanted
to be a hero I wanted to actually do
things that could make a difference but
the response of the progenitor's
celestial here is that may be but you
left the position they gave you the best
chance of doing so the best thing you
could have done was stay on the quiet
Council they're the ones who make the
decisions leaving a position of power
under the guise of wanting to affect
actual change that's a that's a lie it's
a lie you tell yourself and it's a lie
you tell the world what you did Jean
Gray was an act of hubris you wanted to
be the hero so you cooked up some kind
of an excuse that made you feel better
and now you get to go out there and be
the hero and so she initially again
tries to reject this idea of Mind Games
and so there actually comes a point when
Mr Sinister brings himself and Wolverine
into his mind or into the mind of the
celestial in the mind of Jean Gray and
what it does is it allows the celestial
to scan the two of them as what are
basically character Witnesses and that's
the cool thing is because initially it
goes for sinister and it's like tell me
what you think about Jean Gray honestly
and Sinister doesn't really love Jean
Gray and never really has when it came
to Sinister as a person his fan
fascination with Jean Gray was based on
her genealogy remember the old school
basis behind Sinister despite the fact
that it's changed in more recent years
has been the Sinister knew or came to
the realization that if Jean Gray and
cyclops were to ever have a child that
child would be Godly in terms of power
one of the things he says here is he
says I cloned Jean Gray and I couldn't
clone Gene gray I made something else
several times some better than others
but none annoyingly better than her what
he's referencing here is when he created
Madeleine Pryor Madeleine Pryor was the
attempt by Sinister to clone Gene gray
the problem he ran into is he could
clone Jean Gray in terms of her physical
appearance but he couldn't clone the
essence of what made her who she was or
even her powers that's why Madeline
Pryor was never on the same level as
Gene and that's why she was considered a
failed experiment by Sinister when it
comes to Wolverine it's much simpler
than that Wolverine loves Jean Gray so
he will never speak ill of her because
he doesn't see her in any way but a
positive light and that's whenever
everything shifts and you get this
amazing moment in this comic so at that
point the celestial whists away Sinister
in Wolverine and is like enough he says
their Insight helps one who loves you
and one who envies you yes I think I
understand now or at least I understand
enough I met your husband Cyclops he
implied that I should be scared of you a
man who loves you thinks that something
like me should be afraid of you he is
married to something that on a
fundamental level scares the hell out of
him such bravery of course I passed him
he sleeps in the lair of a red dragon
and I think he's right I think you are
like me now this is where things get
really awesome and this is where the
kind of where the celestial sort of
looks at Jean Gray and says we're
similar but we're starkly different at
the same time he says and for the love
you share and provoke that is the part I
cannot get past yes I am destroying a
world but you destroyed a world for no
reason at all and her respect response
is dark Phoenix was not me it was but
it's it's really complicated now to
explain this because I imagine a lot of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
the X-Men Mythos are a little confused
by this when Chris Claremont took over
writing of the X-Men back in the 70s his
idea was that Jean Gray was a character
that had been underutilized in every
capacity but he also wanted to move past
the original X-Men team and basically
create a team of his own hence the
reason why he built on Lynn wines
giant-sized X-Men run but the idea
behind this is that he wanted to elevate
Jean Gray to basically make up for how
her character had been treated and then
write her out in a blaze of glory so he
gave us the Phoenix and the dark Phoenix
sagas right Jean Gray attains This Godly
level of power she ends up going insane
and then she sacrifices her life for the
good of everybody the problem was that
Jean Gray was so ridiculously popular
during that time that Marvel editorial
made Chris Claremont bring Jean Gray
back but what Marvel did is they said
that when Jean Gray initially got the
Phoenix Force the what the Phoenix had
done was actually copy Jean Gray and the
real Jean Gray was just sitting in the
bottom of Jamaica Bay she was ultimately
discovered by The Fantastic Four and the
Fantastic Four brought her to the X-Men
and then what Marvel established was
that when the Phoenix had all that power
it was actually the Phoenix Force
pretending to be Jean Gray when the
Phoenix went nuts and became the dark
Phoenix that it was never actually Jean
Gray it was just the Phoenix had lost
its mind and looked like Jean Gray it
was basically a way to exonerate Gene of
everything that she'd done it still
holds true Marvel's never gone back and
changed that and they probably never
will but that's what she's referencing
here now the funny thing is the
celestial responds and saying yes
sometimes you are a Saint Jean Gray but
at other times you are a violent bully
and above all once you destroyed a world
and that's the thing like she initially
says and I'm going to destroy you and
the celestial says and again violence
now she responds of course in making the
best argument she can she says listen
last month alone I went to a casino
where countless world's Fates were being
wagered on I saved Untold numbers of
Worlds if I were keeping score I'm in
the black block and the response of the
celestial is yes you went to this place
where people were betting on ways to
destroy worlds but your friends would
have saved those worlds without you and
they have not burned at all so basically
the response he's making here is you
cannot use that as some kind of a
justification for all the terrible
things you've done and said look I
destroyed an entire world I killed
countless villains which in reality she
destroyed an entire star system is
actually what happened but like she's
like you know I yes I killed all those
terrible people but look at this great
thing I did here I did this great thing
here and that should atone for it that
should make up for it I've tried to be a
hero all this time and the response of
the celestial is no that's not how this
works she asked the question like what
can I possibly do to make up for this
and the response to the celestial is you
can never make up for this Jean Gray you
are the Phoenix now and forever and the
Phoenix effectively rebonds itself or
seemingly rebounds itself with Jean Gray
in the process but literally what this
means is that Jean Gray when seemingly
she was the Phoenix what this is Marvel
doing is seemingly coming back and
saying actually that was Jean Gray right
we're undoing all that stuff where it
wasn't actually her that was Jean Gray
she was the dark Phoenix it wasn't the
dark Phoenix replacing her or copying
her that was Jean Gray and she did
destroy that entire star system she did
kill all those people there's nothing
you can do to atone for and the actions
of Jean Gray over the course of all this
time after the events of the Phoenix and
the dark Phoenix Saga was never about
her trying to atone for what she'd done
it was never about her saying okay yes I
did that and I'm trying to make amends
right because given the various Heights
of her power she could have brought
those worlds back she could have
returned those worlds during like
Phoenix M song Phoenix War song right
when she was at the peak of her power
when she was in the white hot room the
white Phoenix of the crown she could
have fixed her past mistakes but the
reality is she didn't because it was
never about atoning for her action it
was never about making up for her past
misdeeds she like so many of us out here
in the real world it was just about
making herself feel better about what
she'd done it was selfish that's all it
was it was I did a really bad thing and
I want to feel better about the fact
that I did it so I'm gonna do a lot of
good things and it'll even out right
like the scales will be tipped maybe in
my favor but at the very least they'll
be balanced right like you know it won't
be as bad or it won't be so terrible
that's literally what it was what this
this progenitor Celestial is forcing her
to face is the fact that it doesn't work
that way just because you did a terrible
thing does not mean you get to do an
equally good thing and everything
balances out and All Is Forgiven and the
day is saved the fact and the reality is
you did a terrible thing you did a
horrible thing it's great that you did a
great thing to try to make up for it but
it doesn't change the fact that you did
that horrible thing you cannot atone for
this you cannot make up for this you
can't rinse this blood off your hands
and all the actions that you've engaged
in since then have just been selfish
actions so again it's really amazing
here because once Jean Gray snaps back
and she's back to her normal self she
actually kind of swears out this blood
Feud on the progenitor Celestial and
what's so ironic about this is she
learned nothing from that test she
learned absolutely nothing at all the
basis of the test was to teach her you
have to learn to make up for the things
that you've done what she's doing here
is she's saying I'm going to destroy you
in effect the progenitor Celestial
confronted her with the reality she
doesn't like and like anybody on Twitter
or Reddit or Facebook or just social
media in general she's choosing to
reject the reality of the situation that
she's in and replace it with one that
she finds more agreeable so she
basically lashes out at the celestial
and is like I'm going to destroy you in
your entirety yes I am the Phoenix and
yes I Harbor the power of the Phoenix
and by hell or high water I will destroy
you right I will end you in your
entirety so it's an amazing comic with a
really kind of sad ending for the
character of Gene because again she
learns absolutely nothing what this does
is this basically leads to the
progenitor kind of initiating the end of
the world starting the process of wiping
everything out now one of the things
that progenitor Celestial was
establishing was that the world itself
was pushing back right in the sense that
the world didn't want to end and of
course you also have the superheroes who
are fighting against the progenitor
itself now as for the world we're not
really given a whole lot of indication
there one of the theories that some of
you guys have come up with is that it's
actually the island of krakowa like the
actual Island itself that is helping in
its way to fight against the progenitor
but also remember Captain America was
brought back by the five right by the
mutants and again that's something that
they don't do they don't bring back a
human they only ever bring back mutants
who is part of their Charter right
they're very much self-isolated but with
Captain America's return what it does is
it starts to Rally people and so for a
Time the Earth superheroes really have
kind of Humanity on their side
everything is set aside as far as the
truce goes between the eternals and the
Avengers and the X-Men so on and so
forth things are kind of working out
well but what's ironic about this is
that there are a few holdouts here and
there for example one of the things we
talk about is this guy named Tom right
he's one of the humans that we'd seen in
the story so far a guy with red hair
while the world is ending right
following the Judgment of the celestial
which really is too late for unification
or at least it seems that portals were
being opened by the eternals around the
world that could get people to safety
Tom chose not to take it and in fact he
kept his family with him and the result
is that his family and himself are
basically gonna die because of all this
right so literally his selfishness
doomed his family right doomed to him
and his family and it's just one of
those things where people are responding
in different ways some are hopeful some
are terrified some are very very cynical
but the thing about this is that with
Captain America returning when he comes
in one of the things that Nightcrawler
talks about is how Iron Man Jean Gray
the eternals or at least a handful of
the eternals that they are inside the
celestial itself trying to find a way to
bring it down and the response of
Captain America is that could work
unless it decides to change tactics and
it will decide to change tactics and
that's exactly what the uh what the
progenitor says like yes I'm going to
change tactics right like the reality
here is the Earth is fighting against me
I cannot destroy it with conventional
means or with the means a Celestial
normally would but I will simply go to
the reality Loom right literally the
core of the world and the thing that
keeps it together so what we're talking
about here is the equivalent of holding
a glass together with glue right what
the progenitor is going to do is undo
that glue there's nothing to hold the
glass together and it's all going to
fall apart that's what's going to happen
here right literally he's going to
destroy the world from the inside out
just obliterate the planet and he
literally does that right like rips the
planet open through a fissure and then
starts the process of destroying it that
way now on the inside of the celestial
this is where things get interesting and
this is where I say I think the ending
of this story might be controversial and
controversial insofar as like the ending
of a comic book right I mean it's it's a
comic right it's a fictional story but
the thing about this is you end up
having like Iron Man right you've got
Jean Gray you've got all these guys here
who are consistently facing off against
the antibodies of the uh Celestial but
they finally get to its core right it's
heart if you want to call it that and
when they get there the regenitor just
doesn't really seem to notice them at
all may not even be aware of the fact
that they're there but it's basically
going through and trying to find a way
to end everything now what's cool is
Jean Gray because the because of her
test and the fact that she'd failed
right because she was forced to really
accept the fact that she as the dark
Phoenix had committed heinous acts and
it's one of the things we talked about
in the previous video she was forced to
confront a reality she didn't want to
confront and the result of that is that
it made her angry it basically drives
her to lash against the celestial but
that's when basically Ajax steps in and
actually takes Jean Gray out she doesn't
kill her but she in capacity
incapacitates Jean Gray and stops her
and the reason why is because from the
perspective of ajac this is all simply
just a test right this is all a test
this being performed by the progenitor
and the progenitor even says I mean I
kind of stopped testing but I'm always
watching right almost as if it doesn't
really want to annihilate everything and
so what's kind of cool is that on the
outside you do have the Avengers kind of
doing what they can right you do have
different people out there but you have
like human entity that's also unified
against the progenitor as well now
that's just the beginning because the
numbers are going to increase and in
fact it's really going to become cool
here in a second but what is going on is
Captain America approaches the
progenitor and says like sure like I
can't necessarily stop you but this is
your last warning you can surrender
right you can quit which is kind of
interesting the Captain America
approaches The Virginity like you would
a normal person and when the projector
says you don't have the power to stop me
the response to Steve Rogers is sure but
I can distract you and this basically
leads to a partially returned sign now
for those of you guys who missed the
early parts of the story when the
initial war between the eternals and the
The Avengers and the X-Men kicked off it
was really more the eternals versus the
X-Men what we ended up learning is that
the hex are basically these eternals
that are just ridiculously powerful
right and the reality is we didn't
really know about them before but
they're colossal in size now the hex
itself or at least sign itself is only
partially formed but sign is operating
as a vector and in fact a sign is
operating as a vector for the most
powerful mutants on Earth at this moment
right now the thing here though is that
sign is basically operating kind of at
Allegiance with like Exodus because
Exodus was the Omega Level mutant that
initially destroyed sign and there was a
kind of a respect that built there and
so while science not powerful enough to
kill the progenitor it is powerful
enough to basically offer a distraction
and keep it from going through with like
destroying the world in the moment and
so what it does is it switches over
switches back to the inside of the
virginiter with Jean Gray and Tony Stark
and these different guys and what ends
up happening is Jean Gray you know her
initial response in trying to destroy it
is met by Tony Stark who actually ends
up becoming the voice of reason which
you would never expect
it's kind of weird to see that but it's
one of the things where he says okay
stop and think right and this was Ajax
point right say for example we kill this
progenitor Celestial right now do I say
we we kill this thing in its heart we
eradicate it then what happens the world
saved but all the billions of people who
were killed in his judgment they're
still gone right they're still out
there's no way to bring them back and so
so initially it's kind of like okay well
then how do we pull that off because
Stark's response is there has to be
another way now this is where things get
interesting we don't see a lot of it
orcas gets involved now for those of
guys who don't know orcas is largely a
super secretive organization that's
composed of like Hydra Advanced idea
mechanics humans so on and so forth but
they're staunchly against and trying to
find a way to eradicate the mutant
population but they have Nimrod on their
side and they have Sentinels and what
would have been amazing to see is a
tie-in comic where Nimrod and orcas and
the Sentinels face off against the
progenitor Celestial to see how they
fare because remember when it comes to
Nimrod he has the ability to analyze the
weakness of anybody he sees and then
adapt his powers to overcome that
weakness so there is a legitimate
possibility here that while Nimrod would
not be powerful enough to destroy the
Virgin later it could put up one hell of
a fight but we didn't get that and I'm
kind of pissed
I will I feel like Marvel should come
back and just do like a retroactive one
shot right and just give us us that
story because it would have been
phenomenal to see but the thing about
this is that where Jean Gray initially
tries to blow off the reactions of Tony
Stark and all that initially she's like
you know here's the thing it may very
well be a test whatever it doesn't
matter she tries to attract a virginity
and the progenitor of course disables
her attack and it says of course it's a
test right like I was questioning myself
but I have learned that you do deserve
to die all of you here on this world
deserve to die you remain creatures
guided solely by self-interest you
mutants would kill me as you have less
Stakes some of your numbers would cheer
as loudly as the humans cheered your
deaths those who hate you stand with you
only because there is no other choice if
there was they would take it and the
eternals even when free prove they
cannot change the overall statement that
it's making here is that there is no
unification it looks like it is it looks
like you guys have banded together under
under a singular cause but you haven't
right you're doing it because there is
no other option right like you're
working together because there is no
other option you're not doing it because
you want to you're doing it because you
have to and there is a huge distinction
there and immense distinction there
right wants and needs right expediency
versus necessity that kind of a thing
right that's what we're talking about
here and that's what the progenitor
Celestia was looking for but this is
where things get really really
interesting Tony Stark ever the the the
rationalists right and even like the
eternals themselves what ends up
happening is you actually have Cersei
that basically broadcasts to the world
and she reveals the truth to the world
itself and what she says is that as
eternals the long kept secret that we've
that we've kept away from you guys or
the thing that we've always hidden even
though some of you are aware of our
existence is that every time one of us
dies one of you normal humans dies to
bring us back it's the curse of our
existence but we've known about it for
millions of years we simply just never
told you but now is the time for clarity
right if we are going to really step
forward and if we are going to be a race
that guides Humanity then it's important
that you understand both the good and
the bad of everything that we are and so
in in basically providing that
Revelation to humanity humans respond
exactly the way that you think they
would and it's one of those things where
literally Cersei was doing this just to
prove a point that eternals can change
they've been doing this for like
millions of years so that seemingly
discards the one reality or at least the
aspect of eternals that the gender
Celestial held on to that eternals can't
change but in response Tony Stark steps
up and Tony Stark says here's the thing
none of your judgments make sense and
this is one of the best things about the
story because it's kind of Kieran Gillen
taking the progenitor Celestial and
putting it in place of like cancel
culture or something like that right and
basically saying here's the thing you
have arbitrarily and for no reason other
than whatever reason you decided on your
own put yourself in a position where you
believe that you are a moral judgment
for the world but you're not right you
as the progenitor Celestial are an
amalgamation of us you are quite
literally created by us as just broken
human beings which means it stands to
reason that your line of logic or your
ability to come to these logical
conclusions are just as flawed and just
as infallible for us as people right so
if you are as screwed up as we are then
who are you to make such claims as to be
some kind of absolute moral Authority
you're not right you're just a person
out there ranting and raving about
things that you don't agree with and
that's literally calling calling the
celestial out in that way it's not
enough to bring the event down in its
entirety but it is enough for the
Predator Celestial to actually listen
because there is truth in the words of
Tony Stark but then Jean Gray steps up
and says here's the thing you're about
to eradicate an entire world and it is
time that I come to terms with the fact
that I did eradicate a whole world even
though again Jean Gray obliterated an
entire star system right a whole solar
system is her coming to grips with that
and then in saying if you do this this
is something that you can't come back
from there's no undoing this right you
can't unring the spell you will have to
live with this and if you were just any
normal Celestial out there it wouldn't
matter because it would just be your
role you wouldn't really care you would
have been doing it for ages and ages and
that's fine that's the role those
celestials play right erish and the
judge and ziron the the tester or
whatever that's their place that's their
role but if you do this you will be no
better than us right and you will have
to live with this for the rest of your
life and what it does is it actually
gives the progenitor Celestial the
ability to step back and look at the
situation now that's the controversial
part because I imagine people are just
kind of like really right kindness and
happiness is what brought this event to
an end yes and no so here's the cool
thing that happens right The Virginity
you're realizing that it's not really a
god as it sees itself right that it's
not really an absolute Authority coming
to this realization that because it is
flawed it builds by flawed people that
it cannot be an absolute Judgment of
what's right and what's wrong because
the people who built it don't have an
absolute Judgment of what's right and
what's wrong and its judgment is modeled
after their judgment and so in response
to that what it does is it basically
brings back everybody who was destroyed
right it brings back everybody who died
and then it asks the question like am I
worthy of living right like given
everything that's happened would you
judge in favor of me or against me and
that's literally when Ajax judges
against it and when that happens it
merges itself with ajack and the two of
them are effectively reborn and then
take off to Avengers mountain now
following this with a day more or less
being saved Ajax does return but is a
whole new being she has a whole new
level of power but she's also one half
the progenitor Celestial so she kind of
speaks for it right now this is why I
say it feels like a move on a chessboard
Because the actual climax the event
itself does end with a whimper I won't
deny that right like I was expecting
some great big huge grandiose conflict
but honestly that grandiose conflict has
been happening for the last three videos
that we've made so you can kind of see
how this is just sort of the Tail ending
of it all but the thing about this is
that as the progenitor looks out on the
world what we end up finding out here is
that not everything has changed for the
better that where you had Humanity being
face to force its impending demise that
not everybody looked at those impending
demise as like this is a chance for me
to turn over a new Leaf for Tom it kind
of does to a degree right his family
lives again his son asks you know hey
like like you know what what happened
like I thought the world was ending and
he tries to explain it to his son but
he's trying to have more of a more
involvement in his family's life as
opposed to ignoring it but for a girl
named Katrina because of the fact that
she had sacrificed her life for all
these different people it wasn't some
Jesus christ-esque situation but enough
to where it was noticed by way of the
progenitor from Humanity that instead of
her being humble about it she's actually
become arrogant about it right that she
is she's a little smug because of her
actions like yeah man you guys all need
to bend the knee to me and because of
that what it shows is that a lot of
people out there are still really crappy
Humanity I wouldn't say Humanity as a
whole but Humanity still hasn't
necessarily learned but here's the big
kicker behind all this and this is why I
say I feel like something bigger is
coming which we do know that it is
because of like Thanos with mjolnir with
the Infinity Stones and the hammer and
leading an army of zombies because don't
forget that was something that uh that
Donnie cage teased in his early Thor run
like that's coming right than is
bringing an end to everything again but
like that's that's gonna happen I just
don't know exactly when what we end up
getting here is in the aftermath of
everything there is a treaty that's
formed between the eternals and the and
the mutant population right so now
they're working together which means the
mutant population in whatever conflict
that they're in invoking the Treaty of
the eternals they have Uranus on their
side and remember in one hour Uranus
eradicated 98 of arako on Mars a planet
whose population is 100
Omega Level mutants right literally just
all Omega Level mutants most powerful
mutants there he eradicated 98 of them
in an hour right so like they have them
on their side now now it's one of those
cool things because following that what
you also end up getting is the X-Men
that actually opened their borders to
the world in saying that with all those
people out there who died they didn't
back up every single human mind because
it wasn't necessarily their custom but
they can bring back some but it's more
of them sort of opening the idea of
Resurrection to the rest of the world
and saying like we're not going to do it
willy-nilly we're not going to bring
back just any swinging dick because you
know like you come to us and and you ask
us to bring back a person but you have
no real good reason for why that person
should exist we may or may not bring
them back right you know but if like
some person who is on the verge of
curing cancer just turns blue and kills
over from a heart attack yeah we'll
probably bring them back because their
work was was for the benefit of humanity
that kind of a thing but ultimately it's
one of those where it's it the story
kind of ends in a way where it is in
effect the progenitor Celestial kind of
standing out there and watching out onto
the world and saying like I will never
stop judging you a time will come when
we will enact this again but a time will
come when we will come back I will come
back and I will judge against all of you
or I will judge in favor of you but all
you've done here in this Avengers vs
X-Men event all you've done was
temporarily staved off Annihilation
that's it but once my judgment is fully
complete once the projector realized
that it wasn't able to effectively judge
Humanity over the course of a day once
it's like I will judge you for the long
term and I will compare your progress or
your regression in the future to your
current state now then I will make my
judgment accordingly and when that time
comes there will be no stopping me there
will be no way to Stave off the ending
of things that will definitively happen
and the Earth will either live or it
will be destroyed and that will be it
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace